I like it,
doing it this way.
We should do it this way more often where we get the commercials out of the way
before the guests arrives.
Otherwise it's annoying.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
We've already been busy without you people.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're here with live.
Aubrey Marcus is here.
Oh,
look at that.
That's my laptop at school.
Making noise again,
not old school.
It's this week.
I've done three times a RB.
Marcus is here,
my brother,
uh,
and Mr Pressfield.
Thank you Sarah.
Thank you so much for being here.
[inaudible] exciting for me.
I tried to do this a few times.
I have been giving out your book for years.
I found you know that a sexy beast.
John Meyer,
you know that Sanger is,
you know that guy is John Mayor,
mayor,
one of the fucking handsome bastard.
Uh,
I was reading his Twitter and he said,
uh,
a long time ago.
Something about if you really enjoy for creative types is a great book called
the war of art.
And then someone else brought it up too.
So I said,
all right,
let me check out this book and see what the fuck is going on.
And it's so good.
I bought a stack of them and I kept it in my office and when podcast guests were
come over,
I would,
I'll go committee,
Lazy Bitch,
take this and go right,
go get something done man.
Get something done.
Make it happen.
Um,
the,
the inspiration of that book,
it really works man.
Your book,
like it inspires me to get more shit done.
Like you have a w unwittingly,
more or willingly,
knowingly or unknowingly.
You've liked set an avalanche of creativity loose with your book.
Well,
like I say,
I brought you a half a dozen in the days,
Joe,
so you can give them out to a deserving a worthy recipient.
So I was like,
I was one of those recipients from Europe from the early days.
Yeah,
I gave up on it.
it was before on it.
I gave Arby's that coincidence.
I Dunno man.
Yeah,
I'll probably know.
Is that how's it been?
About three years ago,
Huh?
Yeah.
I gave it to every comedian.
I know that doesn't write new jokes and I'm one that I know I bought it for my
family for Christmas after you gave it to me last Christmas.
Well you know what,
it's applicable even like to non artists.
I think there's a lot of lessons in that about what you talk about though.
The,
the term resistance is a great way of describing it because it's sort of names
this fog that a lot of people have gone through this,
this weird thing that people have where sometimes I'll wake up in the morning
and I'll just,
I'll get online and I'll say,
well what do I have to do today?
I got to work out eventually.
So from between now and when I work out,
what should I do?
Should I go watch TV?
I know the remote is right there and I know,
I know I really should get something done.
I should just sit in my fucking office,
close the door and start writing.
But there's this weird thing that happens where all these other options come up
and it's just so easy to just fuck off and ask you Joe,
cause I don't really know about how comedians work.
What is the thing that you,
that resistance stops you from doing writing jokes,
sitting down and writing jokes.
I would say writing materials,
the big one because it stop you from performing.
Performing is really fun,
you know,
performing as a standard,
but something that we all look forward to and it's,
it's a great exchange with the audience.
This is a great time.
So that's not something that anybody resists,
but they do resist the righting,
the solid Terry sitting by yourself with your thoughts.
You know,
the,
the going over the ideas and trying to make them work and trying to restructure
stuff to make it quicker or have more impact.
You know,
sometimes you,
sometimes you have to,
sometimes you go over a bit and you'll practice it on stage and you'll try to
work it out on stage and you'll eventually get there.
But really what you need to do is do the real work.
Sit by yourself in front of a computer or a notepad,
whatever you prefer.
And actually,
right.
You know,
it's interesting to me as just an audience member because when you watch a comic
that's really rolling,
you figure they're just winging it.
It's just coming out of them,
you know,
the moment.
But it's not true is it?
I mean it's really hard work behind the scenes doing it.
There's actually both.
Um,
there's definitely a lot of hard work behind the scenes,
but there's also a lot of winging it and the w the,
the,
when you get good at winging it,
it sort of comes from already having put in the work and also having your mind
free if your mind is troubled.
Like that's another thing I found,
uh,
as a,
as I matured as a man,
especially over the last like 10,
15 years,
I realize the less clutter I have in my life,
the better my mind works.
Like this is a very valuable thing to keep your mind free of bullshit.
So whether it's people or things you do that you don't like that you do,
or habits that you can't break.
If you can get rid of those,
your whole thing will work better.
Like your mind will actually function better.
It will function without the,
the,
the regret of not being able to take care of whatever it is.
Whether it's a gambling issue or,
I've heard you describe too,
when you're in the zone and doing your best comedy,
it's like the comedy goes through you.
Yeah.
You're just a passenger and that's very much how you described the muse and many
of your books.
Yeah.
That's a very important thing outside of the getting out of the way.
But yeah,
that's a very important thing that you brought up in that book and you set it
in,
um,
sort of a matter of fact way about what's this ethereal sort of whimsical topic,
the topic of amuse like,
but my best stuff,
I have no idea where it came from.
Everything that I've ever written,
every time I've ever been on stage.
I've been at my,
at my best,
I'm like a passenger.
It's like the muse takes you over when you're actually on stage.
Do you
five Joe,
over time,
when you look back on what you did,
a set here are set a year ago that you're discovering who you are as you
long.
Yeah.
Sorta,
you know,
and sometimes like,
wow,
fuck is that even,
you know,
there's definitely a weird,
did that come from element that can,
that can creep in.
But yeah,
if you pay attention.
But a lot of comedians don't like to listen to themselves.
Me included.
Don't like to,
but that's an also a blog
if feel embarrassed when you see your stuff
weird.
First of all,
you're weird if you like it,
you're some that like listening to yourself,
you know,
some guy that gets off on hearing his own voice,
I'm awesome.
And then it's also,
it's like if you're self critical,
which I'm very self critical,
it can be agonizing.
You know,
there's parts of it that you don't like that you just like drive you fucking
crazy.
Huh.
But it's a good way to,
for,
for uh,
creative,
uh,
for like structuring acts.
It's a really good way to realize what my bits are working and what bits aren't
working.
It's to listen to them without having to do them so you can actually hear them
and hear them take place in front of an audience.
It's actually an invaluable resource that a lot of comedians don't take
advantage of for just the reasons I stayed.
And they get embarrassed or they get weirded out.
But there's that thing that you talked about in your book.
It's the Muse and the music exists on stage and the music exists in front of
your keyboard or a notepad or whatever.
The music with some real shit,
whatever it is.
Well,
I'm from the school of it being,
of trying to keep it,
trying to demystify it,
you know,
and because it's,
it is as every day as where do you get an idea from,
you know,
we're nearing the shower,
you drive around the free,
where does it come from?
And the point is,
you know,
to just get out of the way and let those things come and not forget them when
they do come.
Well,
what was interesting about the way you wrote about it as well as it was a very
easily digestible to people because there's some people that talk about the muse
and I just want to smack them.
I just want to throw them off cliffs.
Just shut up like you're killing me with your nonsense talk this.
Cause there's people that,
obviously I'm joking,
but there's people that go so far into the whimsical that it becomes this self
indulgent,
a artistic expression dance.
You know it's like this,
you know their,
their,
their whole thing about the muse.
She comes to me the night I leave the window Shaoshan shall she goes with her
presence in front of my keyboard.
I await her arrival.
Shut the fuck up,
you know Jesus Christ.
But what you were being honest about is I believe a psychological or a mental
state that you're in when creativity,
whatever that is,
works at its best.
And by putting it in your no nonsense terms and putting in in this really very,
very honest term,
like the way you,
the way you are honest description,
the way you describe it as that's what it is.
Like he nailed it and I think that's what John Mayer,
that's what he said,
man.
That's what John Mayer saw and all the sudden one of John's Roxburgh
well you like him are dreaming so you might as well be o shot.
Um,
so you know,
whatever it is that creative people,
when they read your book,
they go,
that's it.
This guy nailed it.
You know that,
that's very important.
What you did is very,
very,
I haven't even
read your fiction.
I've been privileged to watch some of your movies that people would turn into
your fiction,
but I'm just a big fan of your nonfiction.
I'm going to have to start reading a fiction now.
Well,
I brought a couple here that I got there.
I think that you'll like these one is gates of fire and the is tied to
or that sounds like some manly shit.
Yeah,
red tides of war.
Dawn,
what is it about,
yeah,
what is it about?
Um,
gates of fire is about the battle of Thermopylae.
It's not 300 and not that movie,
right?
But it's like a good version of that.
And tides of war is also said in that era.
It's a different,
a different story about,
um,
by 80 Socrates.
Wow.
Cool.
Powerful figures from history.
It sounds daunting job,
but it's not,
it sounds awesome.
I'm a huge fan of history over the last few years especially,
but I'm a big fan of a history podcasts now and we had Greg Proops here
yesterday,
that school this on Columbus proofs is a huge like history buff,
especially when it comes to Columbus.
And he just,
he's a brilliant guy.
So he's rattling off this the history of what an asshole Columbus,
it's really embarrassing that there's still a Columbus Day who knew?
I didn't know what a bad guy,
he was really a bad guy.
But,
um,
I'm a huge,
huge fan of that,
that stuff of just,
I just,
it's so fascinating to me that there was only a few hundred years ago that
people were living this outrageously.
Yeah.
And you got to read some more of his nonfiction too.
I just finished the authentic swing.
Really cool books,
especially for writers,
I think,
you know,
cause it really goes through his process of writing the legend of Bagger Vance
and,
and talking about that.
Really cool to see you kind of refined some of those same concepts.
And for me as you were talking about the Muse and getting really a therial for
me,
one thing that you kind of drove home here is that the muse can be that higher
part of ourselves that we're just tapping into.
And for me that's been one of the key things in my life is finding the ways to
tap into that.
You know,
and I have a bunch of tricks and tools like,
you know,
crazy psychedelic medicine in the jungles of South America,
things like that that helped me get there.
But really the muse can be,
you know,
finding that highest part of yourself,
that part of yourself that's tapped into everything else around you.
And that kind of quantum soup,
as you call it,
the magic,
the source of the universe itself.
And I thought that was a really kind of cool way to draw that in.
Well maybe we'll get you to read that little still.
I'm sure it was.
Yeah,
I would love to.
Um,
the,
the idea of getting out of your own way.
That's a big one.
How'd you figure that out?
I mean,
probably the same way you did.
You know what I mean?
I think it's the,
it's anybody that's trying to do anything in art or filmmaking,
painting,
whatever it is you find or,
or sports or golf particularly,
you find that the tendency is to try too hard.
Right?
You're so you want it so bad,
you don't want to screw up.
You want to get it right.
You want to,
you know,
not embarrass yourself.
Right.
And so you wind up trying,
trying,
trying so hard that nothing comes,
you know.
And finally,
like over,
over time,
I'm sure this is the same for everybody.
You kind of say to yourself,
man,
I just have to lighten up a little bit.
Cause when,
when good things happen is what I'm not trying so hard.
And in many ways,
I think that's the hardest thing of all.
I mean,
Aubrey,
what you're saying about being in the jungle,
you know,
psychedelic juggle,
what that's really all about is not trying.
It's like,
it's like the hardest thing in the world is to say somebody says to you,
relax.
Right?
Or be yourself.
It just be yourself,
Joe.
You know,
I mean,
and,
and yet I think as we become more professional and better at what we're doing,
when somebody says to you,
be yourself,
you can,
you know,
you're not burdened by these false selves and these things that,
uh,
that you think you ought to be or when you want to say,
or how you want to look or what you ought to be.
You've kind of gotten rid of those,
you know,
over time,
deliberately,
very deliberately.
And I certainly have,
you know,
I mean,
I very deliberately tried,
you know,
when I feel myself going that way to pull back and let go.
But,
and I think in many ways that's what any artist does.
As they become a professional at what they do,
they learn to kind of get out of their own way,
and it's the hardest thing of all,
I think,
and the people we talk about resistance or the way people screw themselves up,
right?
That's how they screw themselves up is they're in,
they're getting in their own way,
right?
They're listening to their own bullshit.
They're believing it and,
and they're,
and they're blocked from whatever they're trying to do.
I'm sure that's what the comics,
right,
when they get on stage and they bomb,
right?
That's what's happening.
Yeah.
That definitely is a big part of it.
The,
the,
the what,
what I think you're doing that I think is really cool is that by living your
life and figuring things out and then documenting and sharing them,
sharing them,
like in a really honest way,
we are all providing together what's basically a direction,
man,
you on how to live your life and avoid a lot of bullshit that most people get
involved with.
This is right.
This is the stuff they don't teach you in school.
Exactly.
That's because they don't know we're trying to do.
Now the real problem is the human body and the human mind is probably the most
complicated vehicle that the world has ever seen.
Forget about all the rocket ships and all the,
the different things that you have to go through years and years of school
before they let you fuck with whether it's FAA,
18 fighter jets or helicopters,
there's,
there's a,
I watched a friend get his pilot's license.
Just studying all aerodynamics and all these different things you have to know
to take the test and wins and you'd have to do shit to be a person.
You just a person.
I mean it's way crazier to operate this thing.
I mean it has emotions attached to it.
It can make other people with its penis which likes rubbing.
This is ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous animal and it's a ridiculous
sort of a thing to try to manage with no help.
And by you writing this book and people sharing their,
their own personal experiences.
And this,
one of the things that young men appreciate the most about old men is an old man
who will tell you what he did wrong.
Like when I meet young kids and was like,
dude,
listen to me.
Not going to bullshit you,
but don't do that.
Whatever you do,
don't do this one.
That one's stupid.
Of course nobody listens.
People do.
But if there's that old expression that a wise man learns from the mistakes of
others,
right.
A full Nynex zone zone.
Yeah.
I thought one of the concepts that you brought up that I really like as well as
that,
you know,
it's not so much learning new things,
it's remembering what we've decided to forget upon,
you know,
upon birth,
you come from,
if you have that kind of paradigm of belief,
I don't even think you need it though.
So let's say you come from source,
some kind of near perfect knowledge and then you're born and through whatever
reason you decide,
all right,
I'm going to forget the rules of this game.
And Alan Watts talks about it in a really interesting way of,
you know,
if you did have omnipotence,
what would become interesting,
well interesting would be to figure it out all over again because any known
future is a past,
you know,
if it's perfectly known future,
it's already happened.
It's happened in your mind,
it's happened there.
So you make this pack to forget.
Then you forget everything upon birth and then as you go through life,
you try to remember again as much as you can by tapping in to that eternal part
of ourselves.
And that's a little bit,
I might have gone a little a little astray with what you're saying,
but there's a lot of that that you're talking about it at all with uh,
w with the authentic,
yeah.
Let me just add,
so you have your fairy,
but it isn't right.
I mean there's the,
the various Smith's,
you know,
this thing on her upper lip,
just a little indentation.
Where does that come from?
The myth is that before birth,
we knew everything.
And an angel just before we were born,
touched us right there and nothing came out again or the other.
Another makes sense.
That's what we call an angel in the,
um,
we're a bunch of self,
eight Nass halls.
In the Greek world,
there's a thing that when you were,
you had to cross the,
uh,
the,
into the underworld.
He had to cross the river that the ferryman Tokyo across.
And when you were born again,
you had a drink of the river,
the river Liffey,
And from that four lethargy,
the word comes from as soon as you drank or that you forgot everything.
It was like men in black when they flashed a little thing in front of your eyes,
you know.
Well that's probably analogous,
the psychedelic experiences because a certain psychedelics,
especially DMT,
there's one of the,
one of the aspects of it is that your memory of it goes away almost instantly.
Like you have this incredible trip.
And then trying to remember it is like really difficult.
And one of the ways you remember it is actually,
you remember the way he described it before.
You don't necessarily remember the experience itself,
which is one of the most incredible experiences of your life,
but there's some mechanism that's a racing,
that memory in the human mind and it's the same one.
Interesting Joe and everyone that works on dreams,
dreams,
you forget dreams like that.
Right,
so and there's a way to help retain some of that.
One of the things that we sell is a supplement called Alpha brain.
It's a nootropic.
Nootropics are essentially vitamins and nutrients that have been shown to have a
positive benefit on cognitive function and this Alpha brain stuff.
One of the things that it works great on is lucid dreaming.
They found that people that are practitioners of lucid dreaming this,
this interesting combination of Nutria could control your dream as apparently
they say that what they can do that lucid dreamers say that what they can do is
when they get in a dream,
then it's like they're the people that are really good at it.
They,
they're basically in a movie,
they can fly there.
One of the Avengers,
they're fighting off aliens.
They control the entire show.
It sounds amazing.
It seems like something I should probably look into,
but um,
but for whatever reason I was drawn to it.
Yeah,
there's definitely resistance on that because it's a really fascinating idea.
I've had lucid dreams and the ones that I had once I started fucking around with
nootropics,
they got a lot stronger.
Um,
of Coleen,
there's a,
which is one of the ingredients and a Alpha brand in one,
uh,
one of the big,
nootropics that seems to have a of an effect as does a prasad,
Tim and sandy saying it,
pressing him.
And a lot of those are still working on the acetylcholine mechanism,
which is kind of controls the rem state and that's your dream state.
So,
wow,
you guys tried to,
yeah,
it has an FBI.
We like messing with our mind in a healthy way.
You find out that there's stuff that actually allows you to think a little
crisper.
You know,
I started looking into it many years back cause um,
I read about Bill Roman Halsey who was a football player who's getting a lot of
concussions obviously when he's playing football and he was having issues
afterwards and he developed this supplement called neuro one and that's his
supplement.
It's know added to water and it's,
you know,
this interesting mixture of thing.
And I,
I took it,
I was like,
wow,
this is kind of crazy.
Like this is really having some sort of an effect.
But the point being that that's the only thing that I've ever found that can
counteract that sort of legendary thing of erasing the memory of the fantastic
event because that's a theme.
The erasing the memory of the fantastic event,
the erasing the memory of the brilliant knowledge by the angels.
You knew everything.
That's what we,
you're on Dmt,
you know everything.
You figured it all out.
It's,
you've got it.
I got it.
You sure he got it.
I got it dude.
I got it.
Whew.
Let me back down to earth.
I swear to God I'm a different person.
I get it.
But that that goes into,
it goes away and it seems like this touch of the lip and the drinking of the
water,
it's almost like they're trying to put mythologize this chemical process of the
mind.
I think how this Huxley did a really good job explaining what's going on.
We have this cognitive filter that decides what is useful to not get eaten by
tigers and to procreate the species.
And it's like this gate,
you know,
he calls it the doors of perception or cognitive filter and it's this gate and
it only lets in what is for the animal to
survive.
And so anything else outside of that,
you know,
the brain says,
ah,
we don't need this.
Get rid of this,
get,
you know,
De,
prioritize this because this is an important,
and so what psychedelics do,
what dreams do is they open up the walls of this filter.
You know,
you tell,
look at the mechanism of action as something like,
so assignment,
it's not adding something to your brain.
It's actually shutting down certain parts,
shutting down the default mode network it's called,
which is one of the filtering devices in the brain.
So just more comes in and if you let more in more of that stuff from the,
beyond the quantum soup,
as you say,
you let more of that in while you can get a little bit closer
Dutch,
cause you guys just shutting off your brain like a bunch of fucking morons.
Well you're doing is you should listen to you over there.
You're taking this fucking mushroom and a shut your brain off and you think
that's good.
You think that's a good thing?
Well,
that's what the science is saying.
What do you think Aubrey,
about that?
The idea that door to the theory that when we're children,
when we're infants,
we're seeing all that.
It's like an asset.
If you look at a kid's eyes,
right?
They're not the same as our eyes,
you know?
Well,
they're looking at the room.
God knows what they're seeing,
but it's not what we're seeing.
And that the process of,
um,
growing a little bit older is a kind of a throttling of that aperture right
below that aperture walls.
Every,
every year that we live,
we build more and more filters more.
Yeah.
And we accelerate whatever we do.
You know,
we're trying to push for a promotion at work,
so we're putting in extra hours and I've got to bring home some of my projects
and you know,
your kids are growing older and you know,
they're in daycare and you don't see him,
but you got to,
you know,
eventually we're going to get that vacation house and then everything's going to
come together and went and we complicate our lives deeper and deeper and deeper
as we get older,
almost as if to avoid
silence.
Mm.
You know,
we claimed all be looking for it,
but we just fucking avoiding it at all costs so much lighter after like a
flotation tank experience.
Yeah.
It's just like you can peel off some of these layers and recover just a fragment
of those child's eyes that kind of lighthearted.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's all a way to me this just short of what,
uh,
the PR producing art is about,
you know,
you should,
well,
like for instance,
these two books that I have been talking about here,
gates of fire and tides of war at some point I,
uh,
it's a long story,
but,
um,
I had to come up with an idea for a book and so I brought gates of fire,
which was at ancient Greece and next thing I knew I had done five books about
ancient Greece.
I had never in my life thought about that.
Wow.
I had no,
it wasn't like I was obsessed with it or anything.
I didn't know anything about it.
But some things sort of pulled me into it and kept me going.
So I think in a way that's the,
if you're painting or you're making a film,
you're discovering what you already know.
Right.
And it's,
it's like it was in you,
but you didn't know it was in you and you don't know it's a new until you see it
on the page or it's on a song or something like that.
And what's,
what's
kind of weird to me here,
I've,
I've written like whatever,
five or six books about ancient Greece,
but yet I'm not remotely interested in ancient Rome.
I just don't give a shit.
You know?
It's so why is it a previous life?
What is it?
Some people love the civil war.
They love,
you know,
ancient Ireland,
whatever was all,
nobody wants to play the north in the civil war arena.
They're always playing the south,
but it's like,
why are we drawn to whatever it is we're drawing?
There's a reason.
It's not just nothing.
Yeah.
I don't know about that.
It might be a con the,
an incredible combination of your genetics,
your life experiences,
your atmosphere,
your personal experiences that you've sort of developed a personality around.
There's so many different variables that could lead you to be really like,
I love werewolves.
Yeah.
I've got a four foot tall werewolf in my lobby,
but it doesn't make any sense.
Like,
what's wrong with me?
I don't know.
I don't give a shit about the mummy.
Yeah.
I'm not scared of Frankenstein.
You know,
it's,
it's not really,
it's just a guy or a about that Joe,
is that there is no such thing as a werewolf.
Exactly.
Right.
So stupid.
It's not like I could see being obsessed with wolves,
but werewolf sold there.
So that tells me that on some level there is such a thing as a Werewolf really
tells me I'm a retard,
but you're not,
you're not alone because there are a lot of people watching Werewolf,
at least some archetype that's represented by the,
where right now some itch that,
that scratching,
it's a deeper,
you know,
very well is also,
we know that humans very with a very radically,
we very
in our own lives,
we were not like Beatles.
What we essentially move the same way I do it.
And there's no explosive,
weird actions.
We,
humans are constantly varying,
varying.
Whether or not you're enjoying the,
your interactions with other people or in,
in pain because of them varying.
Whether or not you're an ecstasy because of your movements are just terribly
like stressed out and stuck in traffic and good coming from a job that sucks to
uh,
a marriage that's fucking poisoning you.
There's this of the variations are massive.
So because of that,
the possibilities of each individual interaction that you have with people is
crazy.
So you could run into someone that feels like a wild animal and you know that
that's a part of people and you know that you very,
and then if someone threatens your children something,
this shit does come out of you.
That's so primal that it doesn't even have a language attached to it.
The movements have nothing to do with morality or ethics or law.
They have to do with primal DNA seeking to stay around seeking.
You stay alive.
And that's a wolf.
That's a wolf.
That's what a wolf is.
I mean,
a wolf is prime.
If you've ever had an interaction with an animal,
a real interaction,
even if it's a fucking squirrel that wants to kick your ass,
scary as shit.
Because like we were talking yesterday about baboons and about how evil baboons
are and Greg Proops of saying that they,
they,
they will rush women in Africa where you know,
they're,
they're local and they'll rush women at the grocery store and just fucking steal
their shit and look at him and like you were looking at a monster and just
because it hasn't decided to kill you and eat you,
it doesn't mean it's because it can,
it certainly can.
It's much stronger than you.
It has a face of a dog.
It's got a brain of a monkey and it's stealing your groceries.
You mean that's a werewolf,
that's,
that's this,
this thing of having this interaction with something that has no law to it and
then it,
it comes out of a person.
I've seen that sort of the anthropomorphic side of a thing.
Like we,
we have this idea that the wolves are clever,
like a person as well because wolves are really fucking smart and they do a lot
of creepy shit.
Like they set up people like one wolf will come out and actually walk with the
fake limp so they can like get,
uh,
other,
other people are predators close to it.
Yeah,
they're creepers,
man.
They're really smart.
So you're a student of this stuff.
Wolves.
Yeah.
I'm fascinated by anything that can kill me perhaps or done any vivid dreaming
on the subject of Wolf's?
Well,
I've had some nightmares.
Definitely.
I have one really weird dream that wasn't a nightmare.
Gorilla,
right?
Yeah.
Well the Werewolf and grill,
we're having sex and I was trying to get out of the room for anybody noticed and
I was like creeping like around the edge of the,
the walls,
like really slowly.
And then someone actually sent me a,
a wolf and a gorilla having sex.
Like they,
uh,
they,
they put it together and like this structure,
but the weirdest dream that I ever had,
um,
it was,
uh,
I don't know if I was a wolf or some sort of an animal,
but there was some sort of another animal next to me.
You know,
it's weird to try to remember exactly what it looked like.
It was like something canine,
something like canine,
not a cap and we're walking through this rain forest and water's dripping
everywhere and water's like hitting my nose and I can smell shit that I have
never smelled before and I can smell fear.
I could smell this deer and the deer hears like game of Thrones.
The deer hears a stick snap and the deers fear comes out like a,
like a puff of mist and then I wake up.
It's a weird,
it's a weird dream.
It happened a couple of times where I had this like this glimpse of like an
animal stalking things and smelling things,
but it's most likely just my imagination with all the things that I've read
about like dogs and stark.
I wonder,
I wonder if there's a like a part of us that's kind of repressed in the society
we live in now.
You know,
like we have to apart keep,
yeah,
good amount.
I know there's a huge part of us,
perhaps,
that we're keeping under wraps and saying,
no,
you can't come out and play.
You can't come out and play that kind of savage beast to the animal that's
inside of us that not many of us get to explore at all or release it all,
you know,
back many years ago is,
and these tails,
there was opportunity for almost every adult male to enter this hand to hand
combat where could unleash
this whatever beast was inside of you,
you got to let it out.
And perhaps they didn't really care that much about werewolves at that point
because they got to itch that scratch directly a sword.
So do you think that there's something,
you know,
if you're going to diagnose the,
the male species been particular and then probably another one for the female
that's kind of,
we're struggling with because we don't have that outlet in our society where
absolutely.
I mean,
I think,
and that,
uh,
I was just,
I'm just reading a book about the Comanche's,
you know,
and whatever it would allege 1860 in Texas and the incredible horror that these
cruelty and,
and,
and also incredible endurance cleverness,
cunningness rapaciousness,
you know,
that they exhibited and that's like 150 years ago.
It is so far gone.
The world that we live to drive in a Santa Monica,
get a Carmel Macchiato,
you know,
come back whatever you do.
Right.
And I mean,
I can see just sitting here in this room with the four guys,
there's tremendous testosterone hanging around in this room.
I feel like I want to put an m four and everybody's hand and tell you,
go,
you know,
start killing people and you'll be not here.
I'd be of course,
but I think it's an,
I really think you see this dark side to me everywhere in marriages,
in,
you know,
kids to parents in the dysfunction of the governor.
Look at the government now with the shutdown and all this stuff.
You can't tell me that,
that's not some kind of forced that
found expression a few hundred years ago and doesn't find expression in anymore.
So,
you know,
Norman mailer had this idea years ago that to help stop crime,
he had this idea of an adventurer core.
Have you ever heard about this?
One of his deals was,
you know,
the old,
um,
wind jammer ships that like a would require a crew of 150 to go up in the sales
and sail around Cape Horn.
And it was like,
you know,
adventure wild if he had an idea to have like a hundred of these ships and just
get young testosterone crazed kids out of the bad environments that they were in
and get them,
you know,
facing real shit out there in the real world.
And he thought that,
you know,
that would be very interesting for them and for everybody.
And I think there's a lot to that.
Why do people join the army now?
Why do they want to volunteer for Afghanistan?
Because they care about bringing peace or the American way.
Well,
there's also people don't know what the fuck to do is also that it's a job that
people can get in places where there's no jobs.
The guaranteed living,
you have family that's been in the military.
That's the pivot that people that I know that join the military,
it's usually those things.
Uh,
it,
it's a social substitute for writers passage to another as I have a lot of
people that read my books are in the military.
You know what I may write to me and that da a,
and I can you that,
uh,
they respond to the concept of a code of honor,
the concept of the warrior ethos.
And in fact,
what's frustrating to them about the military unless they're in really elite
units,
is that they don't get that.
It's just the bullshit of,
you know,
whatever it is,
and they're not called on to really perform at the high,
high level that they know they wish they could.
And you guys are into that with your supplementation and the stuff that you do,
you're trying to get to some level that's,
you know,
beyond,
yeah.
I think to summarize what we're saying here is that the problem with the world
is weak bitches [inaudible] dudes out there that a week pitches and we all could
have been a weak bitch or could have been at one point in our lives a week
bitch.
And that's that the lack of discipline,
the lack of a quality character.
That's the one thing that we find like most distasteful and other people,
when you see some weasley God,
it's going to sell his friends down the river.
I remember I was watching punked once and uh,
we're not saying anybody's name,
but uh,
somebody we got punked and they sold their friends out to this fake FBI guy and
uh,
and I watched that.
I go,
that guy is a bitch.
And like to this day,
if I ever see that guy,
I don't say hi to them.
I avoid them.
I'm like,
that's a weasley dude.
That's a belated the coat of arms.
There's no character there.
There's no like,
well,
you're supposed to do the,
the,
the F if it's a fucking card game.
Okay,
what's the worst thing that's going to happen to you?
Dummy.
The FBI comes and they,
you know,
they tell you they're their,
their stone.
You Go,
what?
I've got to talk to my lawyer.
I don't know what the fuck you're saying right now.
I'm talking to my lawyer like I'm done.
We're done talking.
As soon as you say you were the FBI and you're breaking up a card game,
I'm like,
what?
Yeah.
Okay.
Take care.
Good luck with that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm not going to give up my fucking friends like a bitch.
But those people that do do that,
there's scary.
They're creepers.
They're around us all the time.
And that,
that comes from a lack of doing the work.
It comes from a lack of self,
uh,
self analysis of objective thinking comes from a lack of a meditation comes from
a lack of being actually aware of the,
the true nature of your actions,
the true nature of your behavior.
Let me change the subject slightly,
although it's not really changing the subject,
but to ask you a question,
Joe,
okay,
why did you start this podcast and what is your intention,
your longterm intention here?
Does zero,
zero longterm,
and it's,
this is one of those things that sort of made itself.
Um,
we knew of a few friends that had a podcast that they did.
my friend Anthony [inaudible] who's on the show,
opie and Anthony,
he has a basement in his house where he set up a full studio with HD
professional cameras and a green screen and he like,
he'll put like space behind him or New York City behind them.
It's amazing.
It's really cool.
Which by the way,
we're going to get one of those things.
It's called a tri caster.
And my friend Justin,
who was in the other day,
he uses him for is the actual report,
but he did it and it looked cool.
It looked like fun.
He would just have a couple of drinks with his buddies and do Karaoke while
holding a machine gun and he's,
he's fucking crazy.
But,
so Brian and I started it.
Uh,
it'll be four years ago,
December.
Uh,
yeah.
It was just no Christmas.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I just did you sit down and say we want to do this or you now Brian's been,
we were looking for something to do like two to four Joe's fans because Joey had
so many fans and we would make these videos and they were nice but it was so
hard to edit all of this video and only came out once a month.
So we were kind of looking for something that said Joe can interact with his
fans faster for someone who's on the outside looking at the podcast cause you
guys are right in it and I've,
I've obviously been a part of it.
I think what,
what has happened there is Joe is one of the best examples I've ever seen.
If somebody's living his authentic self,
I have in all of my travels and journeys everywhere.
Have I ever met a person who I could count on to be 100% Joe fucking Robin,
you know himself always at,
you know,
at any point in time.
And so I think even without a plan,
his authentic self,
what he was bringing,
what's inside his heart and his spirit was going to play out on this stage
regardless.
He couldn't help it,
you know,
he couldn't strategize or plan what was going to be,
he could just be himself and do the podcast and then here you go.
Here it is,
here's the manifestation.
And that in itself was in lieu of a plan.
I mean I she,
I could tell the sort of embarrassed as you Joe for me to ask you this stuff,
but bear with me because it certainly seems I'm from the outside coming here.
It certainly seems like in a way you or your teacher as this environment here
hedge definitely has to do with maleness,
right?
Short seems to me like asking the question,
he was on your,
you know,
you're,
you're joking about that but you are,
you need it.
A bunch of weak bitches up there.
Well there it is.
It's an uptime like chopper would say.
So you might not have known that when,
when you and Brian started this,
but I think it was kind of oozing out of your pores,
you know,
it could be why,
let me ask you this,
let me,
let's put her in a different way.
What characteristics do you look for in guests that you invite onto the show?
Oh,
they're so varied.
Um,
fun either Joey Diaz type dudes are just funny.
You know,
I've,
I've friends that are just funny,
I just want them to be funny.
It just,
we have just laughs.
And then there's other people who were very philosophical,
these people that I don't necessarily even agree with,
but they have a very well thought out opinion and I like to explore other
opinions.
What I think happened is,
um,
because of what I do,
because I'm a professional comedian,
I'm always looking at things,
but it's also that,
that's who I was anyway.
And it's just,
I found a good job for trying to analyze when I was a young boy.
My parents split up when I was five years old and,
uh,
it was a really bad breakup.
Like a lot of domestic violence and if I had to pinpoint a moment that like that
part of my life made me go,
you know what,
I have a feeling that I just been shit out into this world that no one knows how
the fuck anything works and everybody's just bumping into walls.
And as a five year old I remember looking around cause I just,
I just started going to Catholic school,
which I realized was utter Horse Shit.
I'm like oh great is not really there.
And then my,
my family's not real.
Like religion is not real.
So being like five,
six years old,
I think it made me just start thinking about things constantly.
Like my brain is never rest.
It's very rare that I can just chill out.
Even when I'm watching something,
like I'll have two things going on in the background.
Like I'll,
I'll start playing games with myself in the back of my mind it's like it's,
it's a weird thing like I have,
there's too many things going on in my head at all the time.
So because of that,
like the best way to exercise that is like to find something like a podcast
where you can have a conversation with people for three hours and just sit down
and shoot the shit about things and then explore subjects and no one looks at
their phone,
no one,
you know,
no one takes any emails.
That's a rare thing in this society today.
And to be able to do that and to have that sort of a,
an environment,
for me,
it's perfect.
So it's it,
it's being a student as well as being a teacher in a way.
It's a,
you know,
you're learning,
being constantly fascinated and I think if you're paying attention,
how can you not be constantly fascinating?
The world is just,
every day there's a river of slippery salmon of knowledge and it's,
you can't even hold onto it all.
It's just too much.
It's common,
it's just too much going on right now.
And you look at like the scientific,
just just on the side of just a astronomy,
just the new discoveries that they're showing every day where they just found a
new planets floating in the middle of nowhere with no galaxy.
It's just floating around.
They're like,
shit,
this planet doesn't even to have a solar system.
It's just fucking flying through the universe.
There's all kinds of stuff that could fill your day every day with information
and so more than a teacher.
What I'm as is like a portal.
I'm a portal like,
um,
I'm out there looking for it,
but it's not me.
It's me going,
hey,
look,
did you see that whole it's shit.
And then somebody else goes,
do you see that?
And I go,
fuck.
You know,
it's theirs.
It's a portal thing.
It's,
and having a voice like having a podcast,
it allows people to all like sink in and your fascination with what you
described is key because that enthusiasm that you bring to this is really
important.
There's so many people who are no longer enthusiastic about anything in the
world,
does no longer hold wonder and awe and fascination.
How's that possible?
Where are their socks?
One sock on,
they just get numb.
You know,
you get numb by the world.
You could look at the world as this dark,
great place and it kind of beats on him and he just him down until
they can't see that anymore.
And then you know,
seeing that in someone that they,
that they look up to like,
whoa,
Joe is really fascinated by this.
Maybe I think you can kind of inspire that back in there and you keep that going
just from your natural self.
But you also work,
you know,
you work at it too.
If your meditation,
your flotation,
different things to kind of peel off the weights that can kind of hold you down
and keep those perceptions there.
Keep that fascination alive.
Now you never win.
You never win.
It's a swim.
It's not a,
you know,
it's not a climb.
You don't get to the top of the mountain and plant the flag.
No,
you keep your head above water and you keep moving bitch.
And you have to,
because if you stop,
you're gonna drown.
And that's just a fact.
No matter who you are.
And no matter what you do,
if you stop work,
not everything,
if you stop being aware that you stopped being like present,
it'll all go away and you'll be a shithead.
Again.
I think.
I think we all,
uh,
we all battle with,
you know,
finding our optimum self.
And,
uh,
I think for me,
um,
having things like the podcast,
having things like stand up comedy heavy things like martial arts,
they've all been these avenues where I can figure out how to channel my energy
to be my optimum self.
If there's a,
um,
a quote that I read when I was a young boy,
when I was doing taekwondo,
cause they had like a little pamphlet they gave out the school.
I got really lucky and I went to this,
uh,
Jay Kim Taekwondo Institute in Boston,
which is like one of the best taekwondo schools nationwide ever.
It was a really amazing school cause this one guy who was,
uh,
the,
the main instructor,
he was this brilliant guy,
Jay Hahn,
Kim.
And uh,
that's where I got my black belt from.
And He,
um,
he had a,
he was a brilliant guy at several degrees outside of being a martial arts
instructor.
He went to Harvard and graduated from Harvard Business School was like super
smart dude,
incredible hard worker,
but he broke down martial arts in this,
this pamphlet that they would hand out.
I'll never forget reading it.
It said that martial arts are a vehicle for developing your human potential.
And that stuck in my head when I was like 14 or 15 whenever I was.
And I've carried that with me my whole life,
that quote,
because that's what it is.
It's something you can plug yourself into to find out what you're capable of and
to find out how to optimally be yourself
and to do battle with your own resistance on a microcosmic level,
you know,
and this small,
you're going to have so many things weighing on you that the day before a match,
all these different voices and doubts and superstitions and fears and things
that you can battle and try to overcome so that when,
when it really matters in life,
you get these bigger challenges ahead.
You got practice,
you know,
you know how to defeat it.
He's like,
Oh,
I've seen that old photo and I slayed him a hundred times.
What's great about something like that,
I think like martial arts is,
it's just,
it's a structure.
It's an entire culture that has a rules,
rituals,
orders,
and a young man or a boy comes into that with just this amorphous energy
exploding out of is a year,
his eyeballs and everything and suddenly he's given a structure.
This is how you learn.
You start here,
learn to do this one move,
and then when,
when you've learned that I'll teach you the next move and it kind of channels
everything.
And I think we don't get that in society these days.
Certainly young men don't get that.
You know,
you go to school,
it's basically a kind of a feminized environment,
right?
Other than the football team or whatever that is,
which is again,
a structure and that's again,
that's why people join the army.
I think because they're young guys because they're desperate for some kind of a,
some kind of a way to channel that into something that means something that kind
of,
uh,
provide significance to something.
And I think like it or not.
And most people,
I would say not,
we have caveman DNA.
I mean,
it's just in our system period.
Absolutely.
You either accept that and manage it or you deny it and go fucking crazy and
traffic and wonder why you're screaming and sticking your finger at somebody
because their car got in front of your car.
Like you,
you find yourself loft lost in the wave of rage.
That's possible too.
I've seen ice,
I saw this woman screaming at some woman or some sort of a traffic thing,
just going,
I'll never forget her face going to fuck it.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what,
I don't know what happened.
I mean,
we've all see that usually can blind when you're just zero and you see that
blind rage.
It's,
here's the other side of that,
at least what I was,
I was just saying about,
um,
a structured thing like learning martial arts is something that an individual
can join.
And there are others who are also students and there's a teacher who's teaching
them and telling them what to do.
But the other side of that is art is trying to produce whatever it is you're
trying to produce.
A movie,
a painting,
a book or something like that.
This is where,
at least in my opinion,
you go as an individual and where there are no rules and where or there are
rules,
but you have to discover them,
them yourself.
And so this is what we're talking about before about entering into another
dimension of reality or tapping into another dimension of reality,
which is not,
which is the dimension of potentiality.
It's like this podcast existed before you and Brian put it together.
It just existed on another level and potentiality and on it.
And the stuff that you guys do that also existed and,
or a book that I might write or a movie that somebody might do.
And so I think that is a kind of a,
without trying to sound too phony baloney here,
it's a warrior pursuit.
It's something that taps into that wolf energy or that pure testosterone energy
only.
It's not channeled in a path that already exists.
You,
the artist or the comedian or whatever,
discover that path one footstep at a time and you sort of put your foot out and
you go wrong.
You go into a puddle or you step on a pungy stakers and then you go,
well shit,
wait a minute over here.
This is solid ground and you,
you know this guy,
this got a laugh.
This made people I killed when I did this.
Right?
And so you are kind of in the dark,
like somebody's moving through the dark,
trusting your instincts,
trusting whatever little star light you can see.
And when you finally get to the,
to the end of that far,
so you turn around,
you look back at the path you took for a writer that's a book.
And you look down and you say,
where the fuck did that come from?
You know,
and,
and you realize that that was you all along,
but you had no idea when you started to discover reading that Jackson Brown says
that he writes a song to figure out what he thinks about something.
Yeah,
but he had sex with Linda Ronstadt right back in the day.
He was a stud.
That guy,
you know,
only at John Merrill.
What's wrong with it?
That's very studly thing to do very stuff.
Find out what you want to do is have regular dude singing those beautiful songs
up there on that stage.
So anyway,
that's the way by magic.
I,
you know,
I think,
I think what you're saying is also like what Michelangelo said about creating
sculpture is that he removes the,
he finds the sculpture in the thing.
It's not like he makes it,
he removes all the stuff that's hiding the sculpture.
That's how he looked at it.
You know,
I think so many people that I get questions that they don't know what to do,
you know,
they're just trying to figure it out.
And then I always give him the same advice.
I say,
you know,
practice being excellent at something you love.
It could be trivial,
it could be darts.
I don't care.
Whatever it is,
just be excellent at it puts yourself into,
I think you're right.
On time you'll discover you'll discover something about yourself,
whatever it is.
You know,
a lot of people were,
you know,
we'll look to me to see if they can get a job.
And my question is always the same.
What are you excellent at?
Because if they can show me two random things that they are incredible at,
they're excellent at,
I know that they've learned to apply their authentic self because you can't
truly be excellent at anything without tapping into that or
did that adolescent just what do you love?
Yeah.
What makes you happy?
What's Fund?
Well,
that's the Great William Moulton Musashi quote.
Once you understand the way broadly,
you can see it in all things.
Exactly.
That,
that idea that there's something that you tap into and it manifests itself in a
number of different ways and athletics and artistic,
but whatever it is,
but what you're doing is you're tapping into the same thing.
And that is excellent.
You're tapping into the real thing the way,
and then when you're on the path,
it's going to give you,
you know,
the fruits of your destiny,
so to speak.
Whatever it is,
that's that channel that's going to bring you to the ultimate higher.
You already have practice being excellent,
you know,
you know how to do the work.
And that's another key thing that I love about,
that you always go back to is just,
you know,
how to do the work.
You knew how to take the initial steps that one foot in front of the other to
get there and to see progress and to apply yourself in that way.
Yeah,
I'm definitely a believer in just doing the mundane thing,
you know,
walk into the room,
sit down at the keyboard or walk into the Dojo,
start to do whatever the first thing is.
Um,
it's the same thing.
Yeah.
But I would,
you know,
just something is occurring to me as we're talking here.
I might be,
I haven't even thought about this in a million years,
but you were talking about Aubrey,
about people that don't seem to care or don't have,
uh,
the,
enthusiasm for Sunday and all in one.
Yeah,
I can remember that.
I used to be,
for years,
I struggled like that where I was bored with things.
I was bored with myself.
I was beating my brains out saying,
why don't I love something?
What,
what's,
what is missing?
And I,
my sort of,
my conclusion was that I really did have tremendous ambition and tremendous
aspiration,
but I had buried it under layers of fear.
You know,
as if,
if I would ever admit to myself that I wanted to be excellent at something,
that that would be more than I could,
I could take failure would be more than I could take.
And so when I finally sort of admitted to myself,
and actually it's in the authentic swing,
I think,
or maybe some,
but when I admitted to myself that I did have ambition,
I did want to do something,
suddenly everything changed.
And then enthusiasm did come.
But it was fear.
So I th I think when we,
when we're running into people that are not,
don't have enthusiasm,
don't have that fire,
I don't believe it's not there.
I think it's buried under fear.
And I think,
uh,
I think that's why great teachers,
coaches will put a young person in a position where they can,
they can exceed their expectations or their belief about themselves where they
thought they couldn't do it and then the guy kicks him in the ass enough time,
they actually do it and they go,
wow,
how did that happen?
You know?
And then that's the spark that can then burst into flame if it's,
if it's guided properly.
And I see,
I see that everywhere.
I'm sorry to say,
you know,
in this country it's everywhere.
Well,
I'm glad that you brought up that it was you at one point and you,
you passed it because one of the really important things about your book I think
is that you,
you're really objective assessment,
assessment of your own life.
At one point in time when you were like 40 years old,
you know,
you were talking about this was a long time ago.
Yeah.
This script that wasn't working and you know,
you know,
you were like,
what the fuck am I doing?
And then how did you go from that to completely getting it together enough to
write books about
getting it together?
How did you get over that fear?
Uh,
I think at that time you'd be the fear that I was just talking about.
Yeah.
Well the same thing.
Same question.
How did you,
how did you figure it out?
I think once I realized that I,
that there was something I wanted that I wanted to be a writer,
which I had refused to admit to myself cause I was so afraid of failing.
And then I just sort of said,
well,
you know,
there was a moment,
it's actually in the war of art where I just sort of realized the way you get
there is one step at a time.
You know,
like an alcoholic,
you know,
one,
one day at a time and that it was a,
uh,
a process that could be demystified.
It wasn't airy fairy waiting for inspiration.
It was just sit the fuck down,
put a piece of paper and a typewriter and start,
you know,
and then do that the next day and do it the next day.
And when,
and the other aspect for me was I had no choice that anytime I would try to stop
and try to sell out,
I was like so depressed that I that.
So I just had no choice to just keep going,
going,
going.
But it was before I wrote the war of art I probably been in,
had been writing for at least 30 years or at least trying to do that.
That book came out in about two months just because it was so clear in my mind
that that's what I had been fighting all,
all these years.
Did you find that putting it down on paper helped you?
Very much because it became very clear to me like a law most,
yeah.
I mean for me,
you know,
it's like the way the war of art kind of started for me was that a,
and I'm sure you guys get this too,
it's like friends will come to you and they see that you're getting it to get,
you're doing something,
you know,
and they'll say,
I've got a,
I've got a business in me or a book in me or a movie in me.
And I found myself sitting up with friends,
you don't till two in the morning,
kind of psyching them up saying,
you know,
you can do it.
You know,
and explaining what the negative force was of resistance and how it was all
bullshit.
It was all in your mind,
you could overcome it,
blah,
blah.
And after doing that about 10 times,
and of course nobody listens to you.
Finally I just said I had like a two month break and I just said,
I'm gonna write this down on paper.
And then when somebody comes to me,
I'll just say,
here,
read this and you know,
shut up.
You know?
So that's sort of how that came out.
But it was very clear in my mind from experiencing it and talking about it for
years.
I don't know if that answers your
well.
I think you're,
I think you're honest with yourself and anyone who's honest with themselves,
after enough information comes in,
that's sort of the conclusion they all draw.
Like I'm kind of fucking myself here.
I'm sabotaging myself.
Like,
why don't I know what I need to do?
If I had to give myself advice,
what advice would I give?
Just do it.
Bitch gets get working,
you know,
do what you gotta do.
I lose the last 10 cows.
Will you please shut the fuck?
Cause that's not true.
If you were in a wheelchair from the neck down,
paralyzed,
you're right,
you can't lose that and you,
you're okay,
that's out of your control.
But that's not what's going on here.
This is weird.
Like with this thing is a weird little struggle you've got going on because
people out there that are struggling for real.
And I think in the absence of that,
you know,
there's something to be said about these,
um,
hunter gatherer cultures and the happiness and the hunter hunter gatherer
cultures.
Very strange.
It's like almost devoid of insanity.
Almost a,
we just almost completely cured of,
uh,
mental health issues.
It's really weird.
They have alcoholism if alcohol is introduced into their environments.
But other than that,
when they don't have that,
like happy people life in the taiga.
Did you ever see that documentary?
It's a Werner Herzog's documentary on these people that live in Siberia and all
these guys do is live off the land.
All they do is hunt and fish and trap and you know,
they trapping furs and that's how they buy like snowmobiles and hatchets and
shit like that.
But the,
the majority of their time is just shooting animals,
eating them,
fishing and everybody's happy as fuck.
There's a whole village of people that are so happy.
They're just smiling and laughing.
There's like no disputes.
Everybody's working together to try to get meat.
You know,
they're showing how to like,
like the,
the craftsmanship involved in making these snow shoes and sleds,
they make their own skis.
I mean,
it's really,
really interesting because in the absence of that real day to day struggle that
these people have,
we're almost like,
we were like waiting for something to come along and kick us in the ass.
It's almost like we only react by nature instead of act in some way.
Yes.
Well,
I'm actually fascinated by that stuff to joy.
I've been fascinated by tribal cultures and uh,
but you know,
there's no going back to that.
No,
no,
no.
At some point there was an invention happened in the invention was the
individual and once that was invented,
I think the ancient Greeks invented it somewhere around the time of Socrates.
And before that,
and at that point we no longer had the tribe.
You know,
we no longer had that wonderful,
uh,
thing enveloping us.
But,
but the other,
you know,
if you also,
if you look about,
you look at Afghanistan,
you know,
which is a great place for us to study because we see it in the news that we've
had seen it,
which is like in Pashtunistan you get kind of pretty much tribal culture the way
it was way,
way,
way back when.
And I'm also like when I was talking about reading math of command,
she's a little while ago.
The other thing,
one of the things about tribes is they are unbelievably cruel to whoever if they
capture anybody else or if there's anyone who violates the tribe,
Eh,
you know,
it's not such an idyllic world when you get into that side.
Yeah,
wait a minute.
You mean it's not like avatar
decide they left out of course.
But yeah,
it's almost like that's a,
it's almost a cheat code to happiness.
You know,
that kind of simple life where you're doing,
you're constantly out there doing this world where it's,
it's just we don't know what the hell to do and we don't have action as this
kind of through line in our life of,
okay,
got to go to achieve that next goal,
which is meet that next goal,
which is Fitch.
That next goal,
which is shelter.
It's just this amorphous world.
And we got to figure it out.
And I think one of the things you said is it was really important is you've got
to just do the work and then,
but at the start it's always a leap of faith,
whatever that is.
Like you don't know exactly how it's gonna turn out,
but you know,
you take that first,
that first step,
you know,
and then just trust that if you stay and you show up and you do that every time,
then some momentum going to start going.
It's,
you know,
it's this kind of a cliche,
it's that old Maslow pyramid,
you know,
of where the,
the basic needs of hunger or you know,
clothing got data dot.
And then when you get to the top,
which is where we are,
the needs become,
you know,
cause we have grocery stores,
there's no bombs going off in the street.
So now it becomes self actualization or asking the question,
Joe,
who am I?
Why am I here?
That at,
at all those tough questions,
right?
That the tribesmen don't have to ask because they're too busy fighting off
grizzly.
Right.
And to me this is where something like martial arts or any kind of a discipline
or art period,
the production of art,
this podcast,
your comedy,
whatever it is,
is,
and I don't,
I can't really put my finger on why,
but I think it's an,
it's an answer to this thing of being alone,
being an individual,
being unfettered from the tribal structure or from any structure where we're
kind of floating in space.
You know,
like a George Clooney and w,
you know,
trying to figure out who,
who am I,
why am I here?
What do I want?
Tough,
tough questions,
you know?
Yeah,
very tough questions.
Very interesting questions.
I think that what you said is really important.
That thing of cheat code,
that it's almost like a cheat code to life.
I think what's going on is that's how we're designed.
We're designed to live that and that the variables that we encounter on a day to
day basis are so beyond our genetic capabilities.
The idea of keeping track of 7 billion people's lives,
that's insane.
But that's where we're headed and I feel like in the industrial age from from
the,
you know,
the creation of the machines to today,
we're essentially entering into slowly but surely into a completely new
dimension of reality.
It's like what we've created in just the short amount of time that we've had
electricity is staggeringly crazy.
The idea of the Internet,
the idea of computers,
big screen TVs,
projections,
the things that we can do today,
why find a plain,
insane,
insane stuff and it's just begun.
And I think that what we're facing and what we're going to face over the next
hundred years,
200 years,
this is essentially going to be like a new dimension,
like some sort of a virtual reality where we exist symbiotically with computers
and the Internet and with each other.
And I think that our puny brains,
you know the three or four or five of us in this room,
we're not designed for this new world.
We are,
our brains are going to have to catch up just much like the apes who spoken
grunts had to catch up with these clever motherfuckers over figured out how to
talk with a slippery Tang and actually say names and you know the,
I think it's all a part of growth.
It's all per,
we're not done.
The human race is not,
this is not the finished product.
This is like one step on a long road.
Probably an infinite road and our creations are apart of what's enhancing or
changing or altering the world itself.
Well you were saying,
I think you're absolutely right Joe.
You were saying before that we're cavemen.
And it's true because if you think about the history of human beings from the
time we were homage to today,
you do that long line right?
And He's find that like the law only the last one 10th of an inch is when we
were civilized and it's like,
you know,
a thousand miles the rest of it when we were tribal people.
So we come into this world,
I believe with this tribal template in our mind,
you know,
where it's important to us,
what our friends think of us,
you know,
we act to please others like in high school where you know,
you have to be in the right clique and where this and that.
And uh,
it's only in this,
these last few seconds before midnight that we discover that we're individuals
and we're not wired to be individuals.
And that's where,
to me,
resistance and stuff like that comes in.
That's what sort of would push us back to being the in in the tribe,
in the,
in the mass mind in that kind of thing as opposed to going forward each morning
one step at a time and it's in that dark forest finding out,
you know,
where,
where we are,
what we think,
what we believe.
I think it's a very important point you said about people not being designed to
be individuals and it's very ironic that the people that live in cities are way
lonely or when there's 20 million people around and the people that live in a
tribe where there's 20 people around.
That's so ironic and so strange though.
The loss of community,
like I keep saying with my friends like why don't we just buy houses in the same
street?
Like what are we doing?
Like why do we live so far from each other?
Wouldn't it be cool if you were right there and I could just knock on your door?
Like why don't we figure that out?
But we were so used to this idea of cars driving to homes that no one lives next
to their friends anymore.
And our sense of community depending upon where you live can get like really
sketchy.
Like I was talking to my friend Jim Norton who lives in a giant apartment
building in New York City.
It's fucking huge.
And he doesn't know anybody.
There were all these compartments in this giant cement box and shares with
all these people.
I mean literally if he could walk through a wall,
he could catch,
you could touch someone while they're peeing.
I mean they're right next to his head,
but yet he doesn't know that guy at all.
That's a weird thing that we've created and I don't think we're designed for it.
I don't think we're designed for it.
But I think there's hope and the hope is that we're,
you know,
we're kind of like this meet vehicle with the computer,
Amit vehicle with a computer and then out there somewhere is new source code,
you know,
and just like a new life by Iphone,
we'll just plug in new software and new operating system.
You know when you plug it back in,
I think that's what's going to help us navigate this pass is we got to plug back
into the mother code,
the source code,
and then download new instructions for this meet vehicle that we're all walking
around it.
I think you're only way that the only way to do it.
And so in doing so you'll have all kinds of ancillary benefits,
not only of how to fit into society,
but you know,
as you said,
define your authentic swing,
your authentic self.
You know,
cause that's there in that code to,
and you've just got to find the ways to plug back in
the flip side to what you were saying,
Joe,
is like you were saying that,
isn't it a shame that we're all isolated.
We can't live with our friends,
we can't have kind of the tribe.
And you know,
there's a big element of truth in that in our heart.
But this,
the flip side of that is,
and I feel this a lot is I want to be alone.
You know,
when,
when I'm in a group and I got to do shit that other people want to do or I have
to conform to what their expectations of me are.
Fuck that.
You know,
I don't want that at all.
And the other thing is,
and I'll,
I'll just blow it up if I have to,
you know,
uh,
and the other thing that's really a mystery,
kind of what you were saying Aubrey,
is nobody's ever figured out why we had this big brain.
Right.
We never,
it's not like we incrementally evolved it cause we had to learn to throw a stone
and then we had to learn to shoot a bow and Arrow and it's like all of a sudden
this is why they have all these crazy scifi movies,
you know,
the talk about and we whatever.
But where did it come from?
And I know,
I mean I can feel it in my own head right now I'm using like one 0.0 of what's
up there.
And I know we all are.
So who knows what's up.
We got that.
We got a,
the hardware,
we just don't have the software but the software and we don't,
I mean,
it's obvious too that there's ways to maximize this hardware.
Absolutely.
And some of us have grasped certain areas of it.
Some of us have a grasp it athletically.
Some of them has.
Some of them was like yourself.
I've done it creatively.
Would,
there's all like these weird little,
like this guys figured out this thing.
You now you know how to work your,
this,
you know?
But the thing is so complicated,
the brain,
the body itself,
it's such a weird vehicle.
It's so complicated.
It's almost impossible in this day and age to get it right.
But back in the happy,
the ty got days,
you know,
if you were one of those crazy guys living in Siberia,
you mean there's some shit you got to learn.
Yeah.
Don't go in the river when it's frozen,
you know,
don't,
uh,
don't fall through the ice.
Don't do that.
When a moose
comes run.
Uh,
what else?
this is how saw works.
You know,
there's a lot of shit you don't have to,
are there Joe?
They would kick you out of the tribe and if they don't kick you out,
you'd leave yourself.
No,
you know what I would do?
I would just manipulate those schools.
I figured out a way to start my own call to and I just make up a bunch of shit
and see who's with me.
Speaking at tribes is a little off topic,
but one of the most,
the coolest collections of photographs I've ever seen.
It's from this artist called,
it's that before they.com and check it out.
It's like all the tribes and the ideas before they,
before they die,
before they met,
before they pass away,
before they get assimilated.
And the photographs are stunning.
You know,
they have the eagle hunters in Mongolia and the different tribes from Africa.
So if you want to kind of take a look,
I think the book is about to go on.
Here's another kind of fascinating part about tribalism that if,
if we were to really insert ourselves into that world,
they live in dimensions beyond reality.
We like to think of these primitive tribes has just these guys,
you know,
pounding stones on to Acorns,
but in fact they're things like will,
uh,
whatever tribe it is,
where you need to know where the deer are.
So you dream and in the dream you're told where the deer are or Combo.
That's frog medicine.
When they burn themselves and take this poison and put it on there,
scan it says frog toxin,
and then apparently they can see all the animals in the forest.
That's what they,
I believe it.
It's the same sort of thing.
There's one two days away if I run this way and then they find it should be an
episode of Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
We should take that frog toxin.
See what you find that,
how dangerous is it?
Not Saying I need to know him.
And you go to Suriname and it's uh,
it's dangerous to the frog.
It's the only to the frog.
The frog.
The frog does not have a good go of it,
just harvesting and toxin.
But as far as the humans,
it's perfectly safe so that,
you know,
when the native American,
I just would look at the white man.
They thought we were just a bunch of idiots because we
not tapped into that other dimension at all.
How'd that work out for ya?
Yeah.
That's because the invention of the Winchester rifle.
But other than that,
yeah.
And Polio,
smallpox,
which goes to show you,
there's no justice in the world because they would have won if the,
if there had been any,
just I learned that from ice cube.
No justice,
no peace.
Yeah.
I was in,
I was in Peru and they still,
you know,
some of the old shamanistic tradition,
those cultures still exist and they still have the words for the Spaniards and
the people that came and in their mind,
you know,
part of the reason for the rainbow flag is that's the colors of the shockers
that they see.
Like visually see inside a person who's connected.
And then these other people came in and invaded their culture and they called
him the gray ones because they didn't see that shit.
There was like,
Whoa,
what is this human walking around that has no color for them?
It just because all of that was blocked
up and they weren't kind of tapped in and connected.
So for them it's a very visual thing,
you know?
And you ask them,
well,
why?
What are you talking about?
He's like,
what are you talking about?
Because I see it.
What kind of psychedelics would they fucking around with?
Yeah,
I see there's a different reality when you're consistently altering your
neurochemistry with psychedelic drugs.
There's a,
there's a diff,
I've had moments.
There's the,
the last moment that I did DMT where I said time to take a break where reality
got super slippery for about two weeks.
And when I say buy slippery,
the,
the psychedelic experience was so profound and it was changing my regular
everyday mind so much that I felt like a different person who I had to relearn
life.
Like I was thrown into this life with a manual of this is what you've done so
far.
What are the fuck did I do that?
It doesn't matter.
This is what you did and this is who you are now and ready go like it felt so
unreal for a while that I'm,
I'm convinced that there was some sort of a permanent change in the structure of
my brain or the way my brain accepts certain chemicals are produced.
It seems like a producer's one's in a different way now and I think that if
you're doing that on a regular basis every day,
day in day out,
these people were almost unrecognizable.
I mean they're,
they're all there.
They're reality is they probably seeing flow like D,
we had David Show in here,
David show recently did IOWASCA and now he says he trips every day.
He says,
I don't even have to do anything.
They were all in front of me right now.
I see a dragon in front of you.
It's flying through the air like he sees flying snakes and he goes,
I can just,
I could just see them.
They're around us all the time.
Yeah.
You remember the,
that you're normally used to seeing one layer of the onion and then all of a
sudden you get to here's through all the layers and see all these layers.
And David's not an idiot.
He's a brilliant guy and he's cool as shit and he's not a liar.
So if he tells me he seeing those things,
I believe him 100%.
So what happened to him?
What,
what changed his mind?
What did that to his mind and fried?
Well,
let's,
I don't know.
It's not fried because you're only putting something in that org already exists.
You through the real issue with psychedelic drugs or you know,
anything that's uh,
uh,
a non native chemical that you're introducing into your body.
You have LD 50 rates,
you have low rates of toxicity where it becomes deadly to 50% of the people that
take it.
What is it for DMT?
No one even knows because it's a human neurotransmitter.
It's a part of your natural human brain chemistry.
That's what they're doing when they're doing IOWASCA.
They're doing an orally active version of this DMT.
So if this is,
if he seen fucking floating snakes,
maybe they're there.
We're just not seeing them.
Maybe we're not getting enough DMT on a regular basis.
Yeah,
but if you,
if you take,
if you drink blood or if you take put stuff in your body,
that really bad analogy.
I mean like,
like you're saying,
because it's from your body.
It's not bad because it's,
you're putting it in something that's already been in your body back in your
body.
What?
That's you know more than you had before.
You know?
It's like,
if you
know what you're saying,
you're not taking estrogen.
If he too many soybeans,
it's bad.
Right?
You're not taking out something and putting more in your,
you're adding more to it that you're supposed to have.
So if you have too much blood in your body,
it's probably bad.
Or if you have too much,
you know what I mean?
Any,
anything that's in your bodies,
it doesn't mean it's healthy.
If you put it back in and that's a good point,
but it's,
it's not like blood and it's also the most transient thing ever observed in the
body.
Your body brings it back to baseline.
I'm like 15 minutes from a full blown trip into another dimension to back to
completely sober 15 minutes.
It's because your brain knows how to handle it.
Your brain knows what it is.
It's,
it's there all the time.
Another,
I don't know,
but,
but you've got a good point though.
That's a really good point.
As far as hormones go,
that's a very big point with what happens with guys when they,
they uh,
do steroids.
If you see like bodybuilders,
after they stopped doing steroids,
they usually have to take a bunch of different drugs to try to boost back up
their body's production of testosterone because they just shoot themselves up
with so much and they become the hulk.
I mean,
they're taking like hyper human levels,
10 15 times what a person would be,
you know,
putting into there are just having their body grow.
They're just pumping the shit in their body all the time.
All sorts of different.
So the balls just go,
you don't need us.
And I had the balls just check out.
So obviously putting too much testosterone into your body,
it's dangerous.
Putting too much estrogen has consequences as well.
So in that sense you've got to go,
well,
you know,
I might,
I think we,
we've talked a lot about the drug way to do it,
but there's so many non drug ways to do it.
I mean,
I've had visions as intense as,
you know,
some of the visions on psychedelics in deep meditation.
You know,
when I went and floated,
I had a really deep visions when I do a breathwork ceremony where you do this
shamonic breathing,
where you hyper kind of hyperventilate yourself and get to a state of heightened
awareness,
you start to see some of the similar things.
So for me,
you know,
I hear David chose story and he's already taken care of all of his needs.
That guy has no Maslow,
one,
two,
three,
four are taken care of.
And he's a visionary artists already.
And then he takes something that pries open his doors of perception temporarily,
you know,
turns the Venetian blinds sideways for a while and then all of a sudden maybe
his brain decides,
you know what,
I don't really need to turn them back closed again.
You know,
I can give him open just a little bit cause I'm going to be fine.
And there's a lot of cool information and visions and things out there.
So I think that,
to me,
that's the alternate explanation.
That's a possible explanation.
But he might be right too.
He might have fried his brain,
he might,
he might have gone too far in.
The brain's just not,
it's just the reason why other aspect of this,
as if we're,
if we're trying to imagine our shelter to tribal cultures that are,
you know,
she visions on a regular basis.
Like if it happens to you,
Joe,
you're just an individual without any structure around you.
There's no teacher,
there's no sham and there's nobody who can guide you.
But how do we know that in these tribal cultures,
I mean for hundreds and hundreds,
thousands of years,
you know,
the,
the elders have known how to navigate it.
Here's how you do it.
And you know,
when you,
when you enter that crazy space,
you know,
if there are,
if your uncle is there and he can teach you and show you how to do this and your
brother and then Nada,
maybe that's the way it goes.
And maybe they are living in that world all the time and seeing the dragons and
seeing all that stuff.
You know,
it wouldn't surprise me.
I know,
I know my Iowa
Shama,
I'm pretty well my store Orlando too and off down from Peru and he,
he drinks Iowasca in ceremony probably five,
six nights a week.
Tell me what is Iowasca I don't know what that is.
So it's,
it's a,
it's a psychoactive,
yeah.
Oral,
oral t that they brew from Dmt,
which comes from the [inaudible],
which is like 0.27% DMT or whatever.
And they brew that with an Maoi,
which is a vine that allows it to be orally active.
And so they drink this brew and you have a DMT experience that lasts for four to
six hours.
T is killed in the gut by monoamine oxidase.
So when you take,
like if you're eating grass like flares glass,
it has DMT in it.
And if you were eating that grass,
you're,
you would just start tripping your balls off if your stomach didn't produce this
stuff,
this mono aiming that it keeps monoamine oxidase the,
keeps the DMT from being orally active.
So when they combine the two of them,
when the combine the harming and the,
uh,
the headbutt or of that compound that breaks it down an Aoi,
you guys are deep into this shit.
I tools that I use the tap.
Well,
it's also,
it's,
it's to me,
um,
it,
it's almost makes me sad when someone does know about it because it's so crazy
and it's so real and so vivid and so memorable.
And so life changing.
Uh,
Amber Lyon,
who was our friend from,
she used to work for CNN and a,
now she's become a crazy psychedelic adventure from the podcast.
We were on the podcast and she asked me,
uh,
about ways to change the world.
You know,
she's seen a lot of shit and she's been all over the world and been involved in,
you know,
like covering like some intense conflicts.
And I said Psychedelics,
I think that psychedelic drugs,
he'd change the world.
I think that,
you know,
for some people it doesn't,
for some people just get some high.
For some people they don't want to change,
they don't want to explore.
But if you,
if you want to really see some shit that you didn't even think could be possible
in a movie,
there's,
there's some ways out there.
There's some methods you can,
you could find those methods.
And like Aubrey said,
a lot of them,
they aren't even a drug related.
You can have a naturally occurring psychedelic trip and an isolation tank.
And that's what Mckenna it,
Terence Mckenna believe,
and we were talking about the growth of the human brain,
the doubling of the human brain size over a period of 2 million years,
Trans Mckenna had a whole theory about that being,
having to do with climate change.
And primates experimenting with Psychedelic mushrooms that the rain forests
receded into grasslands and that these chimps started following around or you
know,
are ancient hominid ancestors started following around these cows and that wild
cows and eating the mushrooms that grow on their shit and they were prevalent in
that area.
And he has it like he had it broken down,
he died,
but he had it broken down in terms of the,
the,
the time of the,
the climate change,
and it was very controversial theory,
but one of the best ones,
and it's poopooed because it involves psychedelic mushrooms,
but the reality is anybody who poo poos psychedelic mushrooms has simply not
done psychedelic mushrooms.
Because if you've done them and you blow your mind out and have this in crazy,
the Egyptian icons dancing or in front of your eyes and fluorescent colors and
explain to you the nature of life through a voice that you can understand,
but you know,
as an English,
once that that experience has happened,
you'd go,
okay,
that exists.
That exists.
How many people have experienced this?
How many people have this?
If you gave that to monkeys,
what would happen?
And I think that without a doubt,
that's the most likely candidate.
It's just seems ridiculous because we've demonized all drugs.
We put them all into this big stupid blanket.
And so things like psychedelics,
which may very well be vehicles for evolution.
I mean it might be there looking like a big dinner plate sitting in the middle
of a field because it wants you to eat it so he can tell you things.
And it visual acuity increased in visual acuity.
There's like,
oh,
he had a whole bunch of points that,
that,
that led to this idea.
May the um,
uh,
stimulation of male genitalia,
increased erections when they're eating a psilocybin mushrooms,
the a in small doses,
a measurable increase in visual acuity,
which would lead them to be better hunters,
which lead them to survive better.
Like all these different points besides the psychedelic experience.
All these different points lead to this idea that the animals that embrace that
into their diet would have a better chance of surviving.
You know,
to bring this kind of back to some of the stuff that you wrote.
I know from myself and the psychedelic experience for me,
you wrote,
wrote in your book the authentic swing.
If we find ourselves lost or tormented or in pain,
the reason is that we have somehow become estranged from who we really are,
from the ground of our individual being and for me,
when you know,
when I find myself in those kinds of states where I'm a little sad or a little
lost or a little depressed,
for me,
the psychedelic experience,
like I said,
with or without drugs could be a deep meditation,
could be anything.
It shows me back to my true self and then it can allow me to be happy again and
it's just filled and full of life again.
Can you define Aubrey,
your true shelf as we can?
Well,
I've seen it and I've felt it and I've been at,
you know,
I know when it's,
when it's there,
I know when it's operating the ship.
I had a long experience that actually allowed me to see the differentiating
parts of myself,
the highest self.
Then the,
which I called mine boy because it was very juvenile in the way that it kind of,
it loved puzzles,
love to figure things out,
love.
And then there was the monkey part of me,
you know,
the,
the flesh and blood and testosterone and all of those things were all kind of
coalescing together.
Um,
but the highest self that part of me,
which you know,
is my authentic self is very clear to me.
And um,
it's something that I try to,
I try to get it to run the ship as often as possible and push the mind out of
the way.
Cause the mind constantly wants to take over.
It's a,
I got this shit,
you know,
leave it to me buddy,
I can solve all these puzzles.
Um,
but then when the highest self is in charge,
that's when you're doing your best work more,
but the highest shelf as you experienced it yourself.
I feel like you in therapy.
Yeah.
I feel like you'd be an analyst,
you know,
the highest,
the highest self for me is,
is very,
it's very happy and it's very,
it's very contented.
It's very,
it loves the creation that it's in,
first of all,
and it loves the people of this creation.
And part of what it's here for is to,
I'm saying it,
it's me and it's kind of weird to separate it like that,
but part of what it's here for is to,
uh,
you know,
I had,
I had a vision of it being a,
a nutcracker of sorts to just kind of go through and roll along and spread ideas
and tools and different tactics and things that people can kind of open their
shells a little bit too.
So I saw myself,
my highest self cast,
like a bowling ball that just a bowling ball of light that just kind of rolls
around through the earth.
And,
and that to me,
I know when I'm in that mode,
and not only can I feel it,
not only can I see it,
you know,
visually my mind's eye,
but I know that that's what I'm here for.
You know,
that's my highest calling.
That's my authentic swing is when I'm that bowling ball that rolls through and
says,
hey guys,
have you heard about this thing called Iowasca hey guys,
we tried working out with a Kettlebell or whatever it is.
You know,
part of that opening up the horizons to,
to other people,
this is your highest shelf content with the way the world is or does it want to
help it evolve to something and know it wants to fight like hell to help it
evolve.
It feels that it's,
it's off track a little bit and,
and there's some beautiful things and you know,
I'm not disparaging the world,
but we've taken a veer to the wrong way and uh,
it's ready to the healing grace shimmy the human race.
Yeah.
Red.
Cause you know,
the earth itself is in natural harmony,
but the human race puts the earth's harmony out of balance as well as the
harmony amongst it.
So to bring it back into balance,
it wants to fight like hell.
And it's only happy when it's fighting like hell,
you know?
And when it doesn't want to fight,
it's like,
what the hell am I doing?
I think we're in the middle of it so we can't see it.
I think it's a giant mathematical equation.
The pros,
the cons,
the good,
the bad,
the sucky,
the awesome.
It's all together.
And the resistance almost battles you to make you appreciate when you accomplish
something even more so,
almost
motivates more movement.
Then the worst thing that can ever happen to you is you win.
The lottery does win the lottery at 21.
He good luck.
Fuck face.
Yeah.
Never going to figure out shit.
You have $500 million and you're 21,
you're going to be a dummy for the rest of your life and you have no opposing
force to apply your strength against.
There was something I've read a yesterday or today,
earlier,
uh,
about,
the Prince of,
uh,
one of those,
Brunei or something like that who pissed away $18 billion,
a teen billion dollars.
And that's what happens when you're born with all that cash.
You can't figure that shit out for yourself.
You're just,
you're not going to,
it's,
they said you're at a disadvantage.
Yeah.
It's,
it's life.
You need struggle.
Yeah,
you need all of it and I think that we as human race,
if the in the,
you know,
the macro,
you know from the microcosm of the individual to the human race itself,
it almost seems like all that stuff is necessary.
It almost,
I don't like it.
I don't like it in myself.
I don't like it in other people,
but it exists.
It's always existed.
It never been a day on this planet without war.
What?
What is it?
What is it and what's going on.
Really,
if you were objective and you weren't attached to the life and death of the
individuals that were a part of this race would call humans.
If you weren't a part of that and you were looking at it objectively,
if you were an alien from another planet that wasn't even made of flesh,
you might be going,
oh,
I see what they're doing.
They're forcing themselves to move.
They're forcing themselves to do things.
They're battling over the fucking blood of the earth.
They're forcing themselves to accomplish more and more,
a amazing technological feat so they can kill each other quicker.
They do with these crazy flux and the whole while they're shitting out kids and
an alarming rate,
doubling,
tripling the population like rats on a sinking ship,
hanging on to every Pete of piece of floating wood.
They're nuts.
They're sucking all the fish out of the ocean,
throwing all their shit into it.
They're fucking crazy.
What out of balance,
18 foot or fish has found Alpha Catalina island today.
Oh my God.
It's dead.
Yeah.
Died of natural causes.
The three that the previous one,
longest one that the Aa have found was I think three foot and says,
oh my God.
Yeah.
Does it radioactive?
Did they check it for Fukushima?
I,
Holy Shit.
That's incredible.
Well,
they say there's a lot of fish that just grow until something meets.
Um,
they just,
they don't really necessarily have a lifespan.
They just keep going there.
It's not built in there because you ain't got no chance.
Like good luck.
You know,
there's a leopard seals out there that are looking for your ass seven days a
week.
You're not going to make it so here live forever.
And some of them live forever.
I guess that guy did,
that guy's bad,
bad ass fish or fish
more fish.
Are you writing right now or are you I never stopped.
You don't take a day off after you complete a book or
uh,
I take days off but not,
I have a theory about finishing a book and that is that you should start the
next one.
You should already have the next one or the next two going.
Otherwise you fall into the abyss.
You know,
he nothing to talk about a bis.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean what I mean by that is you resistance and negativity will come up and
you'll get over to your worst side.
You know?
So to me,
I've always got something going and only when I've kind of established a
beachhead in a new project when I kind of know him.
Okay,
then I'll take a little time off.
That's exactly the same with standup comedy.
Ah.
How so?
When you produce a CD or a DVD or a new special is what we call it.
We call it specials because of the way they used to be like an HBO comedy,
Special News Call Your once it's over,
you throw that out.
Like I don't do any of that material anymore.
I might do a one or two bits on a request or if,
if it's poignant appointed,
I know,
but I'll even pointed out that it's an old bit,
but from then on it's all new stuff.
So when I go into a new hour,
if I,
I have to scrounge up all the shit that I'm ready to,
you know,
to really ready to piece together.
I have to have something already.
Uh,
so I have to have something that at least I've attempted on stage or worked out
on paper.
I can't just go up raw and clean and then finished,
finished my hour special and then go,
okay,
now all that material's done.
I have no idea.
What am I talking about next?
Like I always have a few things ready.
Same thing.
Yeah,
what you're saying.
Yeah.
How do you,
um,
how do you ration your time off when you're,
when you're writing?
Do you just write until you feel like you don't want to do it anymore?
Like,
do you,
do you have like a specific amount of time?
Do you make yourself work every day?
I do work every day,
you know,
within reason.
I mean,
maybe I will work one day a week or something like that,
but,
so six days a week I've found,
yeah.
And I,
if I could do seven,
I would do seven.
Sometimes I can do maybe 25 in a row or something like that.
Even if I only do a little bit one day.
But I always try to look at something,
what's a little an hour or something like that.
But I max out at about four hours at that point.
When I start making mistakes,
when I start making typos,
then I know it's time to stop.
And then it's kind of like working out at the gym.
You can push it too far and then you just,
you know,
diminishing returns,
starting to kick in.
But I do think,
you know,
physical fitness I think is a real parallel to that to my experience of how I
work.
You know that you,
you can get out of shape and you can work yourself back into shape.
And when I've been,
when,
when I'm working steadily on something,
I can work longer each day,
you know,
and when I haven't,
when I've,
when I haven't been working,
it's just like going to the gym or trying to run or something you poop out,
you know,
you just don't have enough.
But I'm definitely a believer that the muse comes around every day and she wants
to see you ready to go,
ready to rock and roll.
You know,
even if it's only for an hour,
you're,
you're
saint parallels comedy in so many ways because you,
you get in comedy shape as well,
like standup,
standup comedy shape is real.
It's really critical to get to,
you can,
you can get along without it.
But I've had periods where I've gotten that out of comic shade.
But even though I'm capable of killing still,
there can be a moment where it just,
Ooh,
this is a little off and it's because I'm not in comedy shape cause I'm not
doing comedy for five shows a week.
And if you're not doing for,
you don't want to do too much because if you get too much it gets boring and you
don't want to ever get to that part.
So you want to keep the fun alive with it,
but you definitely want to keep it sharp and when you want to keep it when it's
sharp,
then it's like a part of your natural consciousness.
Like you plug right into it.
You don't go,
oh this is that thing that I used to do.
How's this go again?
It's just zip your,
your mind is firing.
And I think that applies to writing as well.
I think that that getting into that mindset and,
and when,
when you're there on a regular basis,
you get in writing shape,
you know?
And I think that that applies to Jujitsu.
I know.
I know it does to Jujitsu.
When I train,
if I'm not training on a regular basis and I go train,
even if I'm physically in shape,
all that extra thinking that I'm starting that I have to do.
If it's not coming completely natural,
it might.
It might look natural,
someone who's watching it,
but to me I'm thinking like an extra one,
eighth of a second more than I should be.
Whereas if I was in shape I would be thinking at all,
I would.
When you're in doing Jujitsu,
it's just like doing comedy.
Just like writing where when you're in it,
you're in it,
you just flow,
everything moves together and you're a passenger.
You're just letting it all happen.
All your training sort of a manifest itself in the the experience of rolling.
Go ahead.
Back to what you are saying,
Aubrey,
worry about seeing your higher self and then your mind boy.
How would you apply that to what Joe just said?
Well,
the mind boy wants to think about everything.
Once the,
think about the moves,
plan it out,
think about your opponent or just be distracted and think about what you're
going to do when you're finished rolling or what you're going to do the next day
or about some old injury or something like that and you need a kick that guy out
and roll with that.
That presence.
I play songs in my head when I'm rolling.
Like I'll sing the entire song.
Yeah,
distract,
distract the mind.
Boy.
Well I don't know what I'm,
sometimes it's random.
Sometimes they're ridiculously silly songs,
you know,
and they'll just start playing in my head and I'm going over it while I'm
rolling cause I won't allow anything else in there.
I'm just like need Dee Dee,
Dee Dee Dee Dee is.
Especially if it's not a life or death struggle.
Like you know,
you mount some money and you got them pretty much,
you just got to cook them and you got to wait until you can tap them.
When you're in that sort of a situation like you can,
you can force it,
you know,
you could lose lose track.
So I fill up the part of my brain is not required with a song.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's fine.
Mark Tactic.
That's a constant battle.
And,
and to me that,
you know,
I'm a big proponent of the warrior kind of code,
the warrior philosophy and you know,
people think about that in an external sense.
Like,
oh well what are you fighting?
Who are you fighting?
Who's your enemies?
Well that used to maybe make some sense,
but to me the warrior
is,
it's a constant battle with your own mind,
with the parasite of that part of your mind that constantly wants to be active
and,
and that's why you're a wine boy.
You know the mind.
Yeah.
The mind boy,
the parasite is what the total techs call it or there's a lot of different
things.
The inauthentic self,
you know,
you could put a lot of different names on that,
but a warrior is someone who fights against that resistance,
which is another aspect of your mind.
We know that was the original term for jihad.
The real g,
the jihad originally was a fight against your own vices and there was a fight
against your own weaknesses.
It became a holy war.
It was somewhere around the hijacked,
the Mujahideen and the Soviet Union and the CIA somewhere around that area.
I don't know who caused it to change,
but then it became a term for a holy war.
But before it was a holy war was a war against your,
your own self inadequacies.
And I think that's a war that we wage every day.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the key.
The key is deciding that,
okay,
I'm going to be a warrior and I'm not going to accept that part of myself.
That is deficient.
That is lacking,
you know,
but still,
and another concept that I think is important is to have what I called ruthless
self love.
And that's just not this coddling self love of a spoiling grandmother.
Oh yeah,
he eat the candy love.
It's that ruthless self love.
Like this is what's best for you.
I'm looking out for you long term.
I want you to thrive in your life and I'm going to give you what you need to
thrive and nothing else.
You know,
love does not talk.
That nice self love is to get up pussy shit.
It makes it a lot of noises.
Come on bitch.
Yeah.
That's why it's,
that's why it's ruthless,
you know?
But it's not cruel.
It's not going to be that.
It's not cruel.
It's not going to punish you unnecessarily.
Oh,
you fucking fat Slob,
you lazy piece of Shit can happen.
It can happen and then,
and that's,
and that's what you got to watch.
You've got to have that.
That's the self love part of it.
You know,
the ruthless is that intense.
Like come on,
do it,
you know,
get up,
get yourself.
This is what's best for you.
And then the self love part is not to unnecessarily antagonize yourself because
we can be brutal to ourselves.
I mean,
who,
who would we allow?
Talk as much shit to ourselves as,
as ourselves.
You know,
nobody,
yeah.
I think this the um,
the,
the term self love is a funny one because people do you love yourself?
Don't you?
You always knew you loved yourself.
You know people.
There's a weird thing about,
well,
if you don't love yourself,
why the fuck would anybody else love you?
You know you should be a a person worthy of your own love.
And if you're not,
you're doing it wrong.
It's really that simple.
It doesn't mean worship yourself doesn't mean a pretend the or something
awesome.
If you're not,
it means let yourself know when you're not awesome.
Let yourself know everything you're doing wrong and be completely honest with
yourself.
And until you do that,
you're doomed.
You're doomed,
You know how to get it right.
You'd never going to get it right.
If you don't look at yourself the way other people look at you,
or even more harshly,
you're fucked.
And then,
and then the other component is forgive yourself for
these past,
we'll rehash these old things that we've done.
So many are past that becomes new resistance,
these old past deeds that we're constantly lashing ourselves like way to look at
it.
In my opinion.
It's just let yourself know you are not the past.
You are who you are right now and you could have fucked up your entire life,
but right now you wake up and the way I always describe it to people,
pretend that you are a hero in your own movie and the movie just started.
Now your life is in shambles.
What would the hero in the movie do?
A movie that you would want to go see?
What would happen?
How would you get your shit together?
How would the music start picking up?
How would it sounds?
It starts sounding like you know the morning and waving at people smiling.
All of a sudden,
you know you're at the gym,
sweating it out.
You go through this whole montage of scenes with this guy gets his shit
together.
Do all that dummy.
Do all that.
Be The hero in your own movie and it starts now.
You can be a total Lou.
It doesn't matter.
That made the movie will be even better when you turn it all around.
Yeah,
you used to be a total fucking loser and a liar and a piece of shit.
You were fat and lying about it.
He had a fucking belly sucker on.
There's a reason they like Jared from subway cause he was skinny as whole lot.
It's funny,
it's not Michael Phelps,
you know,
Jared from subway used to be a fat.
So that's the whole thing.
And I think going back to you and your books,
that's one of the things that I found really refreshing about your book is that
you were really honest about how you felt about yourself at that time and that
you knew you needed to make changes.
And when people read that it inspires people to get things moving.
Did you know you're going to do that?
When you,
when you made that book,
did you have any idea it was going to have the kind of impact that it's had?
No,
not at all.
You know,
and the,
uh,
those little anecdotes that are sort of storage on my shelf of like,
you know,
the most excruciating moments that it,
those are the things that people respond to the most.
You know,
it's like the worst shit that you could tell on yourself.
The more people can relate to it because they've all,
we've all experienced that same thing ourselves.
And uh,
but no,
I,
I didn't show,
I didn't have any,
but this thing has been out since 2002 and it's just slowly one book at a time
found its way into the,
into the,
well now that you were just on Oprah,
he's going to be on a lot of other people very well.
That helps a little bit young to Oprah and the mail.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I think that what you've done is so important and it's,
it's helped me tremendously.
It's helped a lot of people that I've put in contact with it.
And Aubrey for sure it probably had something to do with him.
Uh,
starting up on it.
Many of these,
I mean even turning pro,
you know,
which is very analogous to the war of art.
And I actually wanted to ask you,
you know,
when recommending,
um,
between war of art and turning pro,
what are the distinctions?
But for me that that turning pro concept was something that I bring with me,
you know,
every day,
it's like,
all right,
what is the pro dude today?
You know,
the pro in,
he doesn't screw around his check his emails and look at his Facebook likes.
The pro goes in to the meat of the problem,
you know?
And that helps me kind of prioritize my day as you know,
CEO of the company.
And the other endeavors that I have to do is like,
what is the pro do right now?
You know,
bro,
it's kind of like your warrior contracts as well,
right?
What would he do?
Yeah.
Do it right.
I mean,
you don't have to do it wrong.
And that's one of the things that we see in involved in politics.
It's one of the things that we see in,
in the corporate world and the impact on the environment.
The corporations are having the impact on societies that they're having by going
into third world countries and setting up shop.
And you know what's going on in China were where they're making iPhones and a
factor that has nets around it to keep people from jumping off the fucking roof.
Like there's gotta be a way to do this better.
You know,
somewhere along the line someone put humanity out of the picture,
put morals out of the picture,
and took advantage of the diffusion of responsibility that comes from people
acting in gigantic groups where they don't feel responsible for their actions.
Each individual feels like they're a part of something much bigger than them.
It's why people don't mind throwing cigarettes out the window.
They don't even feel responsible.
They're not throwing a cigarette in their own house.
Okay?
They're not throwing it on the floor of their living room.
They're throwing a cigarette and then someone else is going to deal with.
Those are plenty of people out there that do that.
It's a diffusion of responses.
Billing.
Yeah,
sure.
Too many fucking people.
It all goes back to that.
We're not designed for this shit.
So what do you think between the war of art and turning pro?
You know,
when I'm recommending these books,
do you still recommend the war of art or what are the distinctions for,
for different people who want to read one of these books?
Well,
I think the war of art is probably the one to read first because it was,
was written first for one thing,
but also it really sort of explains the basic kind of principles of this theory,
whatever it is,
you know,
what is resistance?
What is an,
and turning pro is sort of the answer my answer to how you deal with this
negative force in your life.
You know,
rather than blaming yourself or you know,
passing judgment on yourself,
switch from being an amateur to being a pro,
which sort of takes the judgment out of it all the self-condemnation out of it
so that,
you know,
turning pro would be kind of the second one to read.
If God,
if anybody were asking me why awesome or what order,
what about these books that you gave me?
Which one of those should I read?
For us.
Gates of fire,
tides of war,
uh,
gates of fire,
tides of war is very,
very difficult.
Read.
What are you saying?
I'm stupid.
My favorite book.
How dare you it,
but it's a
Fergal read.
Well,
I'll open it up and you'll see,
okay.
Is it just because of the period of covers or the don't tell me period that it
covers is a really complex period.
And also it's a period,
it's like,
I don't know,
it feels sort of like a blowing,
I don't know.
But uh,
gates of fire is a really simple story with a good,
you know,
good and evil and it's the kind of story that Sykes people up and you're,
when you're done,
you're ready to go out and kill somebody.
You know?
And it's very,
it's a very popular book with a,
the Marine Corps and with elite military units cause it's about kind of the
warrior ethos.
Whereas tides of war is a story that's full of ambiguity and a characters are
not right and wrong.
A lot of people are very flawed.
A lot of bad stuff goes on.
So it's hard to kind of find,
you know,
a character.
You can really root for that.
But it's much more interesting to me because it really gets into the ambiguity's
of things,
which is the way the world really is.
Um,
so read gates of fire first,
let me ask you this then.
As a,
as an author and as a creative writer,
what is,
what is it about people that want that good guy,
bad guy?
Although the Joseph Campbell stuff,
the,
you know,
the ancient archetype or the ancient,
uh,
structure of the,
the hero tail.
Huh?
I think that's exactly Itchio because we're,
each of us is in a battle with that internal monster,
whatever it is or in our,
in our real life.
And we're usually being overwhelmed by that battle.
You know,
we don't understand what's going on or where we're flagging in our passion for
it.
So if we can see a great movie,
you know,
where rocky comes out,
hangs in there against Apollo creed or you know,
you name it,
we kind of come out of it and it's kind of encouraged us and we say to
ourselves,
you know,
it is possible,
if I could suck it up,
if I could,
you know,
be like a,
like you were just saying,
be the hero of the movie of my life,
you know,
starting right now.
And it's why it's a harder sell to do something that's more ambiguous and uh,
we like our fiction,
like with tidy endings.
Like no country for your off for old man pissed me off.
Yeah.
In hindsight,
I loved the performances.
I love the story.
I love Tommy Lee Jones and w who's the,
the guy's name,
he played the psycho that,
that a Spanish gentleman.
Yeah,
whoever he is,
he,
oh,
he's awesome.
But it's,
it's an amazing movie.
And then the end,
you're like,
what the fuck?
Where's the,
why isn't the bad guy dead?
Why isn't the ending wrapped up that why isn't the good guy walk off with the
girl?
What are you selling me?
You know,
I need to see happiness at the end.
I needed it to be.
I think that's one of the reasons we liked the spartan so much is because you
know what the spartan does it every choice.
There's this bracelet's WWJD which is very ambiguous and confusing.
If you actually read the Bible like who the hell knows?
But he does.
Sometimes he brings his sword.
Sometimes he doesn't.
I don't know.
But you know if you said what would a spartan do?
The answer is simple.
You know the guy,
that's what they do.
Yes,
but you know the answer.
Say that a real Sparta.
Why?
What happens?
They get mad at you.
Yeah.
They don't like,
they don't like to live in the reality of all that.
But you know,
for someone like you who knows the Spartan Code,
you know the answer is pretty simple.
You could say what a spartan would do.
And each one of these situations,
and that some part of us is admires that because we have such an ambiguous kind
life,
that
strict adherence to a code is,
well we do respond in stories to archetypes,
right?
Right to the night or the Merlin like character or something like that.
But of course,
and that's what we love.
That's why we love them and stories that gun slinger,
whatever it is.
But of course in real life,
you know,
we're a little bit of this,
a little bit of that.
And you know,
it's not quite so
yeah,
we respond to the Samurai when we,
that's the one that everybody loves.
And when it comes to martial arts though,
the Ronan,
you know,
the one lone person who lives by a very strict code and we like to watch them
practice because we like the watch their discipline and you know,
like in every Steven Seagal movie,
that'd be a scene where he was practicing.
Like there's one where he's in a coma for seven years and it gets out all
sudden.
He's fucking running up hills and throwing punches in the Yang.
Like damn,
he's back practicing.
It's like leaving cigarettes out that burn more time underwater.
Like Dude catching
that Samurai mindset that we know that the Samurai will hold up in combat.
We know that they won't,
that their,
their character will be bulletproof.
They're not going to crumble.
Right.
What does that,
it's an inspiration to us and I think why we like that Samurai,
I'm with you on that Joe.
It's a Samurai's an individual as opposed to the spark and set or a group or
any,
you know,
other kinds of things.
And because we know that we're alone in the world,
at least that's how I experience the world.
And so when we can see the Samurai train and have that discipline,
when there's nobody cracking a whip over his head,
you know,
nobody's paying him.
Nobody's patting him on the back.
Nobody's encouraging and he's doing it all entirely.
Self discipline,
self generated,
self reinforce,
self validating.
That's very inspiring to us because we say,
well shit,
you know,
maybe I can,
I can do it.
And I can tell from talking to you guys,
that's how you live your lives.
You know,
we try to fight that internal battle from the morning.
You wake up in the minute you wake up through the whole day.
One of the things I like to,
I like to train myself,
I'm like,
I write down like,
oh I have a workout routine or write down all the things that have to get done.
You know,
this is all that's going to get done today,
period.
This is going to get done.
You know,
x amount of kettle bell swings,
x amount of Chin ups,
x amount of squats and you're going to do all that.
It's not going to,
you're not going to say enough already.
I don't allow myself,
so I trained myself so I'll write all that stuff down and then I do it.
But I love that I can motivate myself,
that I don't need anybody yelling at me to get all this stuff done.
That's a,
that's very important and I think when you could do that,
like it's so daunting.
The beginning is so daunting looking at that piece of paper.
Do all that shit.
Like right now I'm comfortable.
I don't want to do that.
And then when you just say ready,
go and then force yourself,
it's,
it's the ability to create movement,
the ability to create,
uh,
to accomplish goals.
Like that's a,
that's an exercise that's uh,
something that you exercise.
Just like creativity,
just like your ability to write.
And if the stakes are high too,
when you actually
succeed and you do it,
you start to build that personal power in that knowing that you can put
something down and you will do it.
But then if you pull up short or you cheat yourself a little bit,
you start to build the other ad didn't quite make ah,
it's okay.
You know,
you start to get that,
that weasely Nis about your easily and then so the stakes are higher than just
that workout.
If you go out and set out to do something,
you know,
you better,
you better damn do it.
You know,
at the end.
I actually had an experience today and I'd like to play these games with myself
too.
Sometimes it's a full workout.
Sometimes it's just a set.
And I know,
cause we were doing this podcast,
I was thinking back to the warrior ethos and I know one of the things the
Spartans had to do was they had to run a marathon with a,
uh,
a mouthful of water and then they had to spit the water back out at the end of
the marathon.
Right.
And that was hard training thing.
So I was like,
I've never tried that.
That seems like it'd be really hard to do.
So I set up the treadmill,
you know,
aid and aid and I was doing it to Bata Protocol and which is 20 seconds of
sprinting and then 10 seconds.
Right.
Do that with a mouth.
Yeah.
That's on a marathon marathon thing.
I can have a marathon,
the way hards,
we're running a full marathon.
It was that,
I would think it'd be way harder to do what you're doing.
Yeah,
it was,
well it was,
and it was,
and it was a real mentally,
it was hard to celebrate.
Yeah.
Well,
I said I was going to do around if I was going to do five Ah,
and at three I was like,
wow,
if I just drank a little bit of this water more comfortable,
and I said,
no,
like you can't.
You can't do that.
And then at the very end though,
so I finished my five and the idea was to spit the water back out and then I
thought to myself,
ah,
fuck it.
I don't want to spit the water back.
I'll just,
I'll just drink it.
And as soon as I drunk it,
I knew like
I missed that little bit of my regimen,
you know?
So I cheated myself.
Have a little bit of what that goal was,
was to run the five and spit the water back out this water that you're just,
let me help you out here.
That's silly shit.
You did what you're supposed to do.
The drinking the water at the end,
you deserve that water.
You're absolutely right.
You get a drink water eventually anyway.
You're not depriving yourself of water.
The exercise is to get through the exercise with my mouth full of water.
They're drinking the water,
the other side,
Joe,
your shed to spit the water out the next time when you do split the water out,
you'll feel and then you're going to get another drink of water.
There's a fucking drought.
Why would you do that as a drought going on?
It's a drink.
The fucking water.
That's ridiculous.
Unless you spit into the glass,
then just drink it and then you're an idiot.
Why don't I just drink it straight?
He cut out the middleman.
It's in your mouth or rhythm.
Long as you get silly argument
for awhile,
but isn't it funny though that you recognize that there is,
there's,
there's a thing about cutting corners that's really dangerous.
Cutting corners in life,
settling in life is fucking dangerous.
It'll lead to the,
it's the road to mediocrity.
Let me ask you guys both here.
Was there a moment for you in your life,
your lives when you understood this or it's just,
in other words,
did you not understand this at
a certain point or have this concept and then you suddenly learned it?
I learned it slowly but surely through a lifetime of struggle and failure and
some success and every success cling to it.
Like it's a new log that you found after you were swimming in the ocean to the
point where you thought you're going to drown.
Then boom,
you find a log.
Okay,
we got something.
ready and then jump off that log and keep going and make yourself to another log
that slowly but surely,
I accumulated all this information along with a lot of books,
a lot of documentaries,
a lot of talking to people that I found inspirational,
a lot of martial arts,
a lot of uh,
talking to instructors that explained like what it's about to get through it,
a hard training session,
what it's about to achieve your black belt,
what it's about to be a champion,
what it's about to hit the highest levels and competing.
Competing was a big one.
Competing in martial arts as a boy shaped my brain,
shaped who I am as a human being.
You cannot have any bullshit when you're throwing your bones at people,
when you're,
you're in involved in whatever it is.
With some other trained killer and you're both really good at knocking people
unconscious and you,
you're,
you're planning on doing it to each other,
ready go,
you know your,
your brain does not accept any bullshit.
You have to know exactly who you are and you have to have a very objective
assessment of your abilities.
Otherwise you're going to get brained.
You know you're going to get a bone is going to bounce off your head and you're
going to get concussed.
It's like very real consequence that very rarely faces you in everyday life.
The choices you make very rarely get you cussed.
But when the goal is for someone to knock you out,
like that's their goal.
They're trying really hard to do it and you know that that's the goal.
Like it's like one of the worst consequences you can get in everyday life other
than dying.
You know,
it's,
it's a really hard one.
Your own health,
your own consciousness,
you can get knocked the fuck out.
So that reality I think forced me at a very early age to just cut the bullshit.
Don't cut corners,
look at exactly what it is.
Do everything you have to do.
And also along the lines,
learning that every time I didn't,
I felt terrible and that I felt weak.
I felt if I didn't,
well,
I wasn't in shape.
I felt pathetic.
Like if I didn't,
if I got tired in a match and that's why I lost it was unbearable,
unbearable,
just this stink on me just would never wash off,
you know?
So that's,
that's where I learned
good answer for me.
I'm still learning every,
every day.
Oh,
me too.
Yeah,
definitely.
Me Too.
It's like,
you know,
you think you know and you think you get it and then all of a sudden you'll be
on this weird path and you'd be like,
how did I forget so much just now?
Where am I?
What is this strange place I find myself in?
And you have to research it on my beautiful house.
You have to retrace your steps back and realize that,
you know,
things go in cycles,
where it's at the top of the cycle.
You may feel like you have a good grasp,
but then you'll swing back down again to some lesser state of forgetfulness,
really,
where you have to learn that,
you know,
relearn some things back and be reminded of some other things.
But for me,
I think the process,
one of the defining moments for me actually happened from a movie when this
process was actually when I saw brave heart as a kid.
I remember at that point,
it really like struck me that the impracticality of going through all that
torture just to say the word freedom,
you know,
and I started,
I kind of kind of got,
I was like,
well I kinda got that there was something,
you know,
something else that some other kind of level that you could push yourself
through.
And I remember I would go running and before I would work out and stuff,
I was an active kid.
I love playing around and loved every sport I could,
martial arts,
whatever.
But I was running on the beach and normally when I would have stopped,
I just didn't stop.
And I was like,
William Wallace wouldn't have said.
And saw
some part of me then like some little inkling just planted.
And then,
uh,
I know many other things,
many books,
many teachers,
many internal thing.
Carlos cast the native played a big part.
Um,
you know,
some of the Toltec beliefs,
so many other different things.
You know,
your book meeting,
right
Joe through the immediate people right now guaranteed or listening to this and
they're going,
fuck,
I gotta get my shit together.
And just that sometimes is all you need.
Just need a little spark and then nurture that spark,
turn into a fire.
And that's really what it is.
It's like we,
Hunter Thompson had a great,
I saved it on my phone because,
uh,
I,
I read it online the other day and it's so poignant and beautiful,
but it was about his,
uh,
the quote was about music and about,
some people say that music is a inspiration,
but what he says is he says what they really mean is fuel.
And that I've always needed fuel.
I'm a serious consumer on some nights.
I still believe that a car with the gas needle on empty can run about 50 more
miles if you have the right music,
very loud on the radio,
you know,
and there's something about that.
I find that not just in music,
but in conversations like this that I could,
if I could download this and let's do it as podcast.
If I were in a part of it,
I'd be so fucking psyched.
And the same thing about your book,
I found it through your book.
I found it through certain songs I found through movies.
I found it through performances of a musicians,
comedians,
everything.
It's,
it's,
it exists everywhere around us.
And so it's all saw sparks,
it's all sparked.
He grabbed those sparks and you make your own fire.
That's it.
What are you still learning,
Steve?
Same stuff.
Never.
Never stops.
And I'm thinking listening to you guys,
I mean,
my experience was not like in martial arts or something.
I've got,
it was more in,
in writing day to day of,
would I fuck off today?
You know,
would I drop the ball today?
Would I stop?
You know,
or like Abra,
you were saying you'd running a little farther on the beach.
Like what would we have Mollis do you know?
Um,
can I push myself a little farther?
Or even the idea of like whipping yourself or anything like that.
The idea of like,
um,
being kind to yourself,
be gentle to yourself.
Like if you're training a thoroughbred racehorse,
you're not going to beat the crap out of that horse.
You're going to make it fun for that horse.
Right?
Right.
So to do that,
and like you were saying,
Jill,
you,
you find a log that's floating.
You know,
this worked today.
I did this,
it worked here in is the end of the day.
I feel good.
So tomorrow let me try to do that again.
Right?
And then you don't,
you don't quite succeed,
you know,
but then you find another log and little by little you put those logs together
and truth start to form in your mind or this works,
this doesn't work.
And then also like you guys say,
you get it from other people.
You get it from books,
you get it from conversations,
you get it from music.
It reinforces itself.
Like this conversation now is reinforcing it for me.
And I'm sure it's reinforcing it for you guys too.
It's like what's interesting to me is it doesn't matter what pursuit you're in,
the laws seem to be the same.
You know,
I'm sure that if we had a,
uh,
a weaver in here or a potter or somebody,
you know,
that made furniture,
they would say the exact same thing.
You know,
I get a piece of wood in and that piece of wood is telling me it wants to be a
couch,
you know?
Um,
so it's interesting that there,
there are laws and we're just sort of learning them and uncovering them as we
go.
And again,
this is what Musashi spoke of and this is one of the things that Musashi,
um,
put put in his book where he described his pursuit of calligraphy,
his pursuit of poetry,
right.
There are
disciplines in,
in a pursuit of,
of when you're writing poetry,
when you're drawing something or painting something,
you're still trying to get at that same source,
that pure source,
whatever it is,
whether it's a cartoon or whether it's a Steven Pressfield novel about Greek
history,
whatever it is,
it's the same thing.
It's like,
it's this weird creating energy that you're trying to tap in.
It's getting rid of that mind boy and getting it to the,
uh,
the higher nobler set.
What's the,
what the fuck is the mind boy?
Therefore though is he doesn't need do something good.
He's good at solving puzzles,
is what he's good at.
He's good at pool.
Is He,
is he what makes you play pool?
He's not going to pull it,
but he's good.
He's gonna,
he's gonna doing,
you know,
doing the,
the mechanistic puzzle work of the human life,
you know,
figuring things out,
putting on different masks,
socially adapting,
you know,
modifying behavior in a certain way.
I was call that the ego as opposed to the shelf shelf with the capital Ash.
You know,
it's the,
it's in,
maybe we're talking about tribal ways and and seeing those mysterious worlds and
all that other thing.
Maybe that's the self and somehow when we became civilized,
we shrunk it down to to the ego that knows how to build a wall or something like
that but doesn't know how to access.
And then what,
what you guys are talking about when I'm talking about is breaking through those
walls and trying to get even for just a minute at a time to that,
that thing that's got some magic to it.
Yeah.
Creating and I feel bad for people who don't get it create.
I really do.
Whether W I mean even if it's creating,
like at your job,
you know,
whether you're a,
you're a carpenter or you know,
someone who puts things together.
Like there's something about making something that wasn't there before and now
it's there.
There's something about that,
whether it's even just a performance or you know,
a song or whatever.
There's something about that.
That's one of the few magical things in life.
Well,
let's,
what God does,
right?
Allegedly create.
So we as human beings when we can do that,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
But you're also creates nuclear bombs,
you know,
creating also meant what Oppenheimer did,
it's all creating.
That's,
that's creating as well.
So it's a very strange thing that what you drop out of the Enola gay that kills
a half a million people.
That's creative too.
It's kind of implied.
It's almost there.
That destructive force is also part of,
you know,
is part of the creation.
You know,
I was talking to someone who,
who I really respect and I was asking him about,
you know,
that kind of,
um,
the demon force,
that purely destructive force.
And it doesn't have to be an actual angel or demon,
you know,
kind of conceptualize religiously,
but whatever that destructive forces,
it's tapped in and,
and he's basically saying that,
you know,
when that's really high,
it's just,
it's just doing its job.
You know,
there has to be that,
that opposing force from which creation can push forward.
It's strength,
you know?
And so yeah,
these,
these nuclear bombs do it in a dramatic and terrifying way.
But that's one opposing force by which you know,
you can try and flourish life in spite of,
you know,
so there's some kind of weird harmony in,
in all of that that was created in the soup to begin with.
You know,
everything has to be find the balance,
but I do think that we get way off balance one way or the other in certain ass.
And you see that in people.
And I think the key is,
you know,
you can really only,
there's only one corner of the universe.
You can be sure to change.
And I think that's a quote from,
uh,
from Huxley actually.
And that's yourself and that's what you can be sure to change.
So bringing yourself back into balance,
everybody does that.
Guess what?
The world's back in balance,
you know,
so you can be sure,
take that step to get yourself in balance.
And then slowly all these other things will start to lay out the dominoes.
Will,
I want to ask you a question about writing.
Do you have when you start writing and you have an idea,
like I'm reading Stephen King's book on writing.
It's really interesting.
Yeah,
really good book.
Yeah.
And one of the things that he said that I found was incredibly fascinating is
that he doesn't make a plot before he gets going.
He might have some ideas,
but he creates the characters.
He uh,
he starts writing their dialogue and then what they do is up to them and then
say,
shit just goes down.
And,
which is incredible when you think about the plots of someone's Stephen King's
books,
especially with the gunslinger and you know,
the state what you,
that just came out of your head.
Like you didn't even plot that out.
But that's crazy.
Do you plot your stuff out?
Do you have like a cork board where you put like index cards on it and you move
them around or how do you,
how do you write?
I do sort of,
I mean you have to do that eventually.
Scribner.
You ever tried that?
No,
I don't do that.
It's kind of stuff.
You don't do anything on a,
it's just a,
it's a,
um,
one of those
programs.
It shows you a corkboard and it lets you move index cards around virtual
corkboard.
Yeah,
that's a little too much mechanical for me.
But I do try to,
I mean a lot of times I will start purely on instinct and just take it from
there.
But I think I'm always asking myself,
what's the,
what's the finish?
What is this going to,
you know,
I'm always trying to get the final moment,
the climax and then work backwards from there.
Cause within any idea,
how can I,
let's see.
Uh,
one of the books I wrote was about,
uh,
it's called the virtues of war was about Alexander the Great and the way it kind
of came to me was the first two sentences came to me in this first two sentences
were I have always been a soldier.
I have known no other life.
And I,
when I heard those in my head of style,
that's,
that's great.
But I had no idea who was saying it or where it went.
But I,
so it in a way it's like a finding that the tip tippy top part of a buried
asteroid or something.
So I sort of tried to just partly foe follow instinct and say,
well okay,
what's the next sentence?
You know,
what's the next scene but at this then I'll kind of pull back out of it and say,
what is his fucking thing about why,
what is buried,
what id is buried in those two sentences?
And then,
and then I'll try to,
is this making any sense?
And then I'll try to push it forward to the finish.
What's the climax of this thing?
And cause otherwise I think maybe Stephen King is a genius and he can just kind
of plunge in and just throw shit against the wall and it'll stick.
But I think most of us,
for me,
I'll get lost if I,
if I do that,
you know,
I'll just write this scene and that scene.
The other scene and,
and you know,
there's no,
you know,
I'll get lost in it.
So I kind of need to know if my sailboat is hidden for Tahiti.
That helps me a lot.
Then I know I got to go south of Hawaii and you know,
north of Ltd is so,
um,
for me,
in other words,
it's kind of a combination of instinct and just winging it,
but also then pulling back to the left brain and asking,
what's this about,
where's it going?
And,
and then structuring it back from,
I don't know if that
answers your question.
I don't know.
I,
it's,
it's interesting cause he didn't go too far into depth as far as what I've read
at least that,
um,
he died,
I don't know if,
uh,
along the way he writes things down or sets up an ending along the way,
or he might,
he's one of those,
he might fucking write the ending first.
You know what I mean?
Who knows?
I have no idea.
But his point being is that when he's writing,
he's just sort of,
he's not following,
like today he's going to write down that Sally meets Betty and Betty can let on
fire with her tits.
You know,
if you have the idea of Kerry,
right.
You know that the climax is going to be Carrie,
you know,
blows everybody away.
Right.
So you don't have to be to analytic to figure that out.
So we kind of knows what's coming.
Hmm.
Maybe,
maybe he might not have known that that was gonna.
You know the carry one's a really interesting one because he was throwing that
away and his wife pulled it out of the trash.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
that's,
that was his first big break.
His wife pulled it out of the trash.
It was like,
listen,
don't,
don't quit this one.
But that goes to show you though.
Oh,
final power.
A lot of times we don't even recognize what great stuff.
Dot.
Well,
it's also probably because he was drunk and on Coke and his dad as well.
You can use it.
I mean,
he may be the option.
Maybe he was sober.
He goes off about his,
uh,
his massive amount of drug use when he was writing books.
He wrote entire books that he doesn't remember at all.
Cujo apparently it doesn't remember at all.
Has Your money.
You can read it for the first time.
It's awesome.
This is great.
Boy.
Talk about a movie that doesn't hold up.
I tried to watch Cujo the other day.
I was like,
shut this fucking stew that talk stupid.
Shoot.
That fucking dumb thing smoothly sucks.
Like it wasn't scary at all.
Do you,
um,
you've had quite a few of your movies,
your books rather than it become movies.
Is that a frustrating per say,
but,
well,
the legend of Bagger Vance was how many different movies or books have you
written?
It,
it become moving.
I think that's the only one.
I mean I've had,
I've written screenplays but that became movies.
But uh,
uh,
let me put it this way.
I've never had a good experience yet.
Oh Wow.
You know,
maybe uh,
I'm unlucky but I've never had a good,
I'm sorry.
I thought you had at least two that had become,
maybe it's just forgetting.
How many screenplays have you,
uh,
have,
have been made from your books?
Yeah,
I'm not sure.
Maybe five or six years.
That's what I read.
Um,
so your all terrible.
What is it about that?
Like they can't,
it's is it because of trying to condense it to an hour and a half,
two hours,
whereas a shitty job from the star,
you know?
No.
Is it the Hollywood machine that that takes something and can take your ideas,
which are like,
as you were talking about the tides of war,
there's some ambiguous characters and
it's a,
yeah,
I wish I knew Joe.
You know,
I think sometimes writers get really lucky and you know,
the godfather comes out fantastic,
right?
You know,
every scene is perfect,
you know?
Um,
and other times,
you know,
and then there's,
there's the,
the sort of the,
um,
the politics of,
of Hollywood where like if you're casting,
um,
the character of Bagger Vance,
let's say,
and you want to cast Morgan Freeman who seems like he would be the perfect guy,
but they run the numbers and they say,
well,
Morgan Freeman is not going to justify a budget of x,
Y,
z.
So maybe we need to,
so we can't cast him.
We have to care.
You know,
in other words,
decisions are driven by factors other than I would have to,
other than instinct,
you know,
I would have to disagree sir.
I think some of your movies
amazing,
including King Kong lives above the law.
Well you weren't.
You made above the Law Free Jack.
I was one of three good misery people.
That was the only one I ever actually liked
above the law.
It's Randy Davis,
the director.
I mean,
look,
I everybody goofs on time gall but above the law was fucking great at the time.
Moving is Steven Seagal movie.
My 14 hours shouldn't because there's the one that launched him.
Dow was the one that was the best above the law was the best one.
There's a lot of silliness to it.
Of course there is,
but it's a God damn cop movie.
It's about a bad ass guy who's kicking ass and you know,
fucking people out.
There's no way to do that where it's not silly.
And Army of one with Dolphin London can really do that.
Please.
Holy Shit Man.
You guys were going to do this.
The,
uh,
someone told a fib and Brian caught him.
W why is it about a King Kong?
I mean,
what is it about,
uh,
the terrible,
terrible.
That was what that was the movie that was going on in when you were 40,
when you were talking about your life being in a shambles.
That was that movie.
Yeah.
What is it about King Kong that we keep making that fucking movie over and over
again?
Happens.
Archetype.
Gorilla thing is a werewolf,
I suppose.
Yeah.
No,
it's worse because the same goddamn story.
He always falls off the fucking building.
An American Werewolf in London is different than the man with Benito del Toro.
Yeah.
It was a lot more places to go when they keep redoing that Goddamn King Kong
movies,
the same fucking thing happens every time.
It's like nobody ever figures that they can make a King Kong movie where he
doesn't die.
You know?
Do you understand that it was a movie that like somebody made it to begin with
like a stone tablet.
You can do a whole different King Kong story,
but nope.
Nope.
Got a blonde girl,
get a building climb,
shoot him down,
done.
What is,
does that frustrate the shit out of you as a creative guy?
Like would they want to keep doing the same goddamn thing over and over again?
Well,
I'm not even sure how to answer that too.
I'll be there.
There's,
you know,
I want to do the same thing over and over again.
Sometimes it'd be,
there are sort of principles of storytelling that you want to do,
you know,
but I mean,
I know what you mean.
And it is,
it is pretty frustrating.
What do you,
you know,
you give a lot of advice for writing fiction in this,
especially the authentic swing.
Um,
but what about some of your nonfiction works?
You know,
how is that different?
How is that process different than crafting a story and characters?
Um,
cause you've done amazing job,
you know,
writing nonfiction as well.
Well,
of course the only nonfiction I've done is stuff about the writing process
rather than something like,
uh,
you know,
um,
uh,
all the president's men or something.
Right,
right,
right.
So that's kind of,
yeah,
but that's sort of the specialized genre,
didactic kind of self help.
My theory is,
uh,
that it has to be a story anyway.
You know,
it,
uh,
my partner Shawn Coyne is a big believer in act one,
act two,
act three,
no matter what it is,
even if it doesn't have any characters,
it's got to start somewhere,
have a middle and then have an end.
So I sort of tried to follow the same,
the same process,
make it a story a little bit
where the reader plays,
uh,
plays a role then.
So the reader is kind of the,
the protege and you're the
mentor.
The reader follows along rooting for you or you know,
even if you're on your character is only salted in there a little bit here and
there,
you know,
going from one fiasco to another,
to another bed at all,
sort of if,
if,
if you do it right,
it has a flow to it and it builds to a climax.
Like the war of art starts kind of out with,
uh,
it's in three parts.
My partner,
Sean figured that out.
You know,
it's,
it's what,
what is the enemy resistance?
Second part is what's,
how do you,
how do you overcome that enemy turning pro?
And the third part is getting into the metaphysics of it.
What does it all mean?
And that's sort of a natural progression,
you know,
what's the,
what's the metaphysical aspect of it?
And at the end,
what's the,
what's the spiritual side of it?
Right?
That's this,
that's the aspect of what you've written in your book that makes it not really a
book about writing.
It's not really a book about the creative process.
It's a book about achieving a mindset.
It's a book,
a book about achieving a victory over this resistance thing.
And uh,
the,
the achieving this state of mind that just,
no,
there's no nonsense.
Cut Out all the nonsense and get to it state of mind.
You know,
it's like a,
it's a psychological handbook.
Yeah.
It's the writing as,
as you know,
I think you even point this out.
It's just a metaphor for the process.
Same what?
Same with golf,
which I didn't even realize when I was doing it kind of became clear afterwards.
Are you a big golf man?
Is that why you keep writing?
And I was stuck off
when I was a kid.
I was,
I grew up as a caddy,
you know,
so from the time I was like 11 till all the way through college,
back in the days where the worst such things just caddies.
So I kinda grew up in the caddy shack,
just like a,
you know,
Rodney Dangerfield.
And uh,
but since then I haven't really been able to play.
So really why is that?
I'm working for a living.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
So you don't give yourself a chance to like take a little day off and go play
golf.
I mean,
I do that every once in a while,
but I'm so lousy.
It's pretty depressing.
You know?
It's like,
I remember when I graduated from college to New York,
got married
first day we moved into the city,
the car,
my car was vandalized and they stole my golf clubs.
I didn't play for another 20 years,
you know?
And then by the time I did then,
you know,
it's interesting was all in my memory,
the love for the sport,
it seems to bleed out in this and the,
I love this.
I love the game.
It's a game.
Weird people
watching golf more than you like,
well,
I would love playing golf more if I played below better than I play.
So do you get very self critical on yourself when you play golf?
Is that,
uh,
bring up a love that I,
I mean I've been so bad for so long that I kind of forgive myself now.
You know,
it's like,
isn't that part of now my,
my main goal is just not to hurt myself,
you know,
get through it.
Try to enjoy,
not kidding either.
Do you walk in or do you take the cart?
Uh,
well I,
I tried to walk when I can,
you know,
but I'm pretty much Karcher the way it is these days.
You know,
I think people are being pussies.
I think if you,
if you're gonna knock that ball that far away,
you should go walk off.
Nice.
I agree with it.
It's too bad.
Then you should carry your own fucking clubs evolve to that point.
It's we're cowards,
we're were cowards and pussies.
So we will have other people carry our clubs and getting the thing.
It's fun to drive those when you're,
it is fun to drive those,
but the problem is play some serious golf.
You need to whack that fucker and then walk after it.
Problem when you really suck though is if you walk,
there will be people just so mad at just right behind you cause it's taken
forever.
You got to go walk to the left and you got to walk to the right and then you got
it.
It looks as if it's me.
Then you walk to the left,
you know,
I'm all over there.
It's so cool.
I was in,
um,
I guess it's like Beverly Hills the other day at a meeting and I'm uh,
at this,
uh,
network and I'm looking out the window and they have this giant view of this
golf course and just the mass of the golf course.
I had to take it into my head.
I'm like,
how much is that worth?
Like,
I guess it was Beverly Hills Country Club or one of those big country clubs down
there.
And I'm like,
this is a giant piece of land in the middle of like the most expensive real
estate in the country.
Like this is crazy.
That's a $300 million plot of land.
It is amazing.
That's La Country Club.
It's two courses there.
So that's a lot of lamp.
I imagine what that's worth.
It's nuts,
but it's what a,
what a wacky sport.
You're going to walk around the land,
you know,
and it rains,
you're fucked.
You know,
it's a crazy sport where you need a giant piece of land and so like influential
as far as like business meetings and you know,
people that love to like get together and play golf together.
It's like,
it's a big part of the comradery
I think for business.
It reveals something about the person you're playing with.
That's pretty unique because it will bring to the surface.
Those parts of themselves that are a little ugly are a little weird or noble and
and good.
You know,
when you play with somebody,
you get to know more than just your conversation,
you know,
because you see if they're going to fudge it and they're going to cheat a little
bit if they're going to get really self critical.
And I get all mad at Ryan Callahan
had a,
an instance when his father was playing golf with this man and his mother was
there and his mother watched the Guy Playing Golf with his dad cheat and then
told them,
do not go into business with this guy.
And she told him why.
And he was like,
Whoa,
like in Brian as a young man remembers that.
Like that's just,
it's just a game.
And she was like,
no,
it's not.
No,
It just a game.
It is just a game of,
so why did he cheat it?
Just a game?
Because that's what he does.
That's who he is.
That sleazy motherfucker.
Yeah.
So in that,
yeah,
you can learn,
but I've heard women complain.
Um,
it's an interesting argument that there's like a patriarchy thing about these a
men's club meetings on golf courses that they could never get in on this and
that,
you know,
the,
they would never be in,
even if they were in that circle,
they would almost like be,
it would be the white elephant in the room,
you know,
and that they would have to learn how to play golf and go in order to have a,
like an equal stake in the companies and an equal stake in the future.
You have to kind of be a part of this little goofy club of these fuckers chasing
after a ball.
It's very weird.
They can learn.
It's not MMA.
Yeah,
but why should they have to,
I mean,
shouldn't it be the men ideally.
Right.
But I do,
well,
some of them do though.
That's the thing,
in order to be like in that sort of,
they are people that in order to be in the group with them,
you have to do the things they do.
They have to,
you have to like the kind of music they like and it's a part of the tribe thing.
It's a part of our tribal instincts.
You have to be,
you have to have like two people don't like working together.
If one's a Republican and one's Democrat,
they fucking hate each other.
You know?
And,
and I've seen it in offices like this fucking liberal breeding hard over here
and it was guy.
Everything will go bama over.
And then there's another one that's fucking redneck asshole over here.
You know,
if he could have his way,
we,
you know,
we don't have slavery again and there's,
that kind of shit is just,
it's so prevalent.
It's interesting that the,
the,
the game of golf sort of like,
it encompasses a,
an aspect of that tribal behavior.
You know?
I think you can probably do that with most sports too.
I mean,
how much do you learn about somebody when you roll with them,
Joe?
Oh,
you'll learn every,
learn everything,
right?
You learn everything and learn who they are,
especially when they're tired.
Yeah.
We learned a lot of that person when they're tired.
Some dude's can keep going,
so I'm good.
Just fucking fall down.
They just flatten out.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
It's um,
it's,
you learned about pool too.
Same thing,
same thing.
Pursued any,
any sort of a pursuit.
It's,
if it becomes hard,
you know,
you learn who can keep it together,
who's going to fall apart.
Just,
you know,
and,
and doing this,
it's the practice for,
for the life,
you know?
And I think that's why I always innately people who've been in athletics,
male or female,
I have such a much greater affinity towards and trust,
you know,
when they've been to a high level and they felt that pressure of fans and
obligations and expectation and pushed through,
you know,
I know the feeling when you know,
some days and these biggest games in high school,
we'd get a couple thousand people's Texas
sports and it would be so intense.
I would just want to go to sleep before the game.
I just want to curl.
It has just really tired right now.
But then you get out there and you feel the rush and you put your,
you know,
put your forearm into somebody on that first play and get your first hard drive
to the basket and then this feeling just kind of explodes and you,
and you're in it,
you know?
But making it through that process without folding.
There was also other games where I never got that kind of restrictive energy out
and I played like shit,
you know,
just terrible.
And you learn about that.
You learn how to deal with the pressure,
not internalize it,
push through and,
and men,
so many times in business and these challenges,
you know,
it applies,
it applies.
Pressure is to deal with pressure.
Exactly.
You got to get used to that bitch.
Gotta feel her and what she does,
how she tricks you,
messes with your head.
That's it messes with your head.
You've got to learn that too.
That's a,
that's the big one.
Just like,
you know,
essentially it's resistance.
It's the same thing.
That doubt,
that creeping doubt makes its way.
You got to figure out a way.
Yeah.
Boy,
and we are all luck contributing to this.
A collective guidebook of how to be a human.
You know,
you know,
one thing I've just recently started playing with that it occurred to me that
there's little fears that we think of as trivial and a trivial fear,
like a fear of spiders or,
and there's also things like,
for example,
for me,
I have this block about doing a backflip on a trampoline,
even like a super safe,
super big one.
And I can back flip into pools.
I can do,
yeah,
I'm a fairly athletic guy,
but as soon as I go to do it on a trampoline,
which is fairly soft,
my body just freezes up and I lock and I was talking to my friend about it.
And for me,
you know,
when you allow these fears that are disproportionate away from the actual danger
to take hold,
it's almost giving credence,
you know,
giving resistance,
like this little bit of victory that can apply to other things.
Or if you're so afraid of spiders,
you can't even look at it.
You know?
Just by doing that,
it's acknowledging that you have some certain limitations,
you know,
and it's giving that other force that's going to limit you in life and deny you
from achieving your goal.
Just a little bit more power.
So even for me,
and this is something I'm just recently playing with these little trivial fears
that we just kind of avoid like,
ah,
this doesn't matter.
You know,
who cares?
What am I going to see a spider?
I don't know.
I'll fucking deal with it when it comes or cares if I do a backflip on a
trampoline,
you know,
in effect that practically it doesn't matter.
But as far as doing the little things to battle against these forces that are
constantly looking to confine us,
I think maybe it matters.
You know,
like maybe pushing through these seemingly trivial things.
It counts.
You know,
it's an exercise.
Set yourself the task Aubrey,
to do that.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I decided that like last,
like a few days ago,
I haven't been home yet.
I'm walking out to the trampoline and I'm pushing through that moment where my
legs just say,
Eh,
nobody,
you're not doing this and I'm going to do it.
I hope.
I hope I can.
I don't know,
but I'll see y'all video.
Figure it out.
I would guess that the backflip is a metaphor for something else,
for you.
Stands for something.
Right.
And I mean,
we all have that stuff.
For me it's like claustrophobia.
Yeah.
You know,
elevator,
certain elevators.
I can't get on airplanes,
you know?
And I know that it's,
it relates to other stuff,
you know,
it's not,
it's not isolated.
Yeah.
Have you ever done a sensory deprivation tank experience?
No.
Never have.
Oh,
you need to get,
well,
you do it.
If I hook it up for you,
I don't know.
I don't look like a claustrophobic in there.
That's what I'm saying.
You got we through that.
Come on,
man.
Will tell me what is the walk?
It's a tank that's filled with water and a,
you've ever seen the movie altered states?
Yes.
That's it.
Uh,
is a tank filled with water?
The water's the same temperature as you're scanning and it's filled with salt.
So there's like a thousand pounds of salt in the water and you lie down in it
and you float,
you float your above,
you breathe cause your,
your body is a half underwater.
But there's so it's so dense with salt,
the float,
he closed the lid on the door and you're in complete silence.
Complete darkness.
Your ears are actually already
shouldn't panic.
Can we leave the door open?
Oh No.
Nope.
How dare you not walked.
The walk is going on here.
We're learning so much about Steven Pressfield.
Yeah,
it's um,
but if you are,
if you really do have an issue with Claustrophobia,
that'd be the place to curate it with great way to get through it.
Yeah.
You'll get through it 100% because it's the most claustrophobic place in the
universe.
Oh,
sounds
great.
Separates you from your body,
but they're amazing at a coffin.
Let me explain to you what it is.
The benefit is when you're in that water,
your water is,
the water is the same temperature as your skin so you don't feel the water.
You're floating,
so it's a feeling of weightlessness,
total silence,
total darkness,
a complete absence of sensory input.
So because there's nothing coming in,
your brain is so much more powerful.
It's a weird thing.
It's like the way I describe it as like if we're having this conversation,
there was a Jack Hammer next door.
It'd be very hard to concentrate.
We would want to move away from the sound of that Jackhammer,
but life is a Jackhammer to Jackhammer on your ass.
When you're sitting in this chair,
like as we're sitting,
your ass is constantly sending signals like,
Yep,
that's a leather chair under my ass,
you know?
Yup.
These are things under my armpits.
Yet there's Aubrey.
Yup.
There's Steven Pressfield.
The,
this is a wood table.
There's the shit's all coming in and we just don't,
we just completely take it for granted.
When you're inside that tank,
nothing comes in.
You're floating in space,
completely weightless and in the absence of sensory input,
the mind becomes supercharged because the mind has all this resources that all
of a sudden are available that he thought it was going to have to deal with the
weight of the body and moving along the ground and avoiding objects and social
cues and all that stuff it doesn't have to deal with right now.
So the mind has all these resources free and you,
it becomes a very self examining self,
uh,
objective analysis of a,
of your life.
It almost like a seminar on your life and then it becomes a psychedelic
experience and more comfortable you get with it.
The more you have like visions.
But I think for you creatively,
man,
the things that you would come up with inside of that tank would be amazing.
Once you got over it,
he got a couple of bucks by
man,
have a panic button put in amuses.
They're ready to visit tab and start seeing Steve.
I'm going to force you to walk the walk.
Sir.
This is ridiculous.
You need to get in there.
Aubrey's done it.
He loves it.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a really interesting experience.
I think the same for these fears.
There's our superstitions.
I've realized too that you allow these superstitions to persist and that's just
another head on the,
on the resistance hydra,
you know what I mean?
And,
and I noticed this of compulsive shit that people do today,
you know,
today was,
it's a podcast where I'm reaching them a lot of people and so I'm kind of amped
up.
And so I was picking my Kombucha is,
and I was like,
oh,
which one should I pick?
And then all of a sudden I was like,
well maybe I should pick this one over this when I was like,
hey dummy,
like stop being superstitious.
They're all this things like it doesn't matter.
We're thinking that if you got the wrong one,
you'd have a bad time on the show.
Yeah.
Maybe not all that far,
but I was like,
this one has better than the other one.
And then I did,
I just stopped myself and I was like,
just because there's like a pressure to vent,
all these little things will come out.
They normally,
normally I'd just rip that thing off the shelf,
never think about it.
But because you know,
as you said,
you're moving from lower to higher and I'm trying to bring my best self to this,
to this show,
you know,
I was like stressed about these little things and then I had to stop myself and
say,
Hey,
this is bullshit.
Like you can't allow these trivial things to bother you.
It's just another form of resistance in this point because the pressure's on.
So your mind's like,
oh there's a lock and omens and if the birds fly this way or that way,
you got to get rid of that shit too.
You know,
these trivial fears and these trivial superstitions,
you know,
I'm really think that you got to cut those out,
and just ruthlessly,
but I'll take the other side of that,
getting that topic.
I think
there is luck and I think there is funkshway or whatever it is.
I mean,
if you think about people are getting married,
right?
A couples getting married put in tremendous thought rossed me,
but doesn't everybody puts your thought into what day are we getting married or
where are we getting married?
Are we going to get on a cliff and Malibu or whatever it is and why did they do
that?
Because it's going to be either lucky,
it'll be lucky for them.
Or like when you're naming a child and you're trying to say,
well what name am I going to give this child?
Right,
don't you?
What do you think so or not?
You feel like shit,
if I gave this my daughter the wrong name,
it's going to fuck up her entire life has changed with the armory or vice versa.
The right name.
Yeah.
So I mean you're saying that you were saying before,
right,
that there are dragons possibly flying through the air that we just can't see
you right now cause we're not in a psychedelic state.
Why isn't it true that there's luck in,
in,
you know,
I mean certainly the Chinese Japanese believe in it,
right?
You get,
I just think it's,
I think it's a slippery slope and it can,
it can,
it can be a virtual,
you look like someone like Raffi on the doll.
It's somehow he makes it works,
but he's got a tie in retires shoe,
you know,
12 times to get it right.
You know,
if he doesn't get it right,
he's not going to play that point.
Right.
You know,
and he's going to have you get,
you can bring it to its logical conclusion.
You can take it to floats.
Yeah.
It's logical conclusion is always in the realm of wackiness that there's nothing
there.
Sure.
You know,
I,
I can't prove it,
but I think they're shopping.
I think it has to do a lot more.
I mean,
I,
I think it has a lot more to do with your own kind of intent.
You know,
when I go to Vegas,
the only game I like to play is crap.
So anybody who's played enough craps and rolled the dice,
you gotta be a little bit,
you've got to believe in La a little bit.
I mean,
you'll feel these moments where you just feel invincible.
Cool you.
I was out pool tool as well.
There's,
there's some guys who a w when you play nine ball,
I play in a lot of tournaments and nine balls.
There's a lot of luck involved in nine ball.
There's a lot of skill because he played from one to nine,
but any ball that goes in,
even if you don't make it on purpose,
it counts including the nine ball,
which is the game winning ball.
So there's some guys that just ride the nine ball like he,
they get ball in hand when they scratch.
So they'll set up a ball behind another ball and just whacked that ball and the
nine ball hoping it bounces around the table and falls in somewhere.
Because if it does,
they win.
And there's this one motherfucker that I play in this front of it with that
drives everybody crazy because every time he gets cue ball in hand,
it doesn't matter if there's three balls in the table,
one of them is the nine,
he sends up all in it and I wax it and lets it fly her out.
But when he's on a hot streak,
they fall,
they fall like rain.
And it's,
I've seen it happen and I've seen this where people go,
motherfucker,
this guy,
just one again.
Uh,
you know,
and he won by just total luck.
Just crashing the balls together.
And that nine ball finds a way into a hole somewhere and he,
when he's on,
it's tangible.
Yeah.
And,
and to me the distinction is,
is you're putting out your own internet,
you know,
and I think there it is,
there is a key in the universe there.
There's kind of a,
an access point where if you put your intent and put your belief in into that,
whether you're rolling dice,
I do,
and it gets a little fuzzy here,
but I believe that there are some forces at work,
this kind of momentum force that causes seemingly chance events to more line up
in your way.
And I know this is a very controversial topic,
but it just feels that's the way I can't,
I couldn't prove it of course,
but that's the way it feels to me when I'm in those moments.
You know where,
where he feels like you can control things that you would think are out of your
control by the will of your own intent and belief.
And that's,
you know,
not just my belief.
That's the belief of many of the shamanistic cultures that
that's really interesting.
That can't be statistically proven.
What's really interesting,
I had a Sam Harris on the podcast.
He's,
he's coming back again at the end of this month and he was talking about the hot
hand,
a phenomena of basketball.
We're guys just,
just all net.
Oh,
they just can't miss statistically.
It's not real.
Well,
no.
Did that,
that study,
I have a big problem with that study because the way they helped me,
the way they did that study as they measured the hot hand by when three baskets
in a row when it,
well,
anybody who's played basketball knows I can be,
have my head in my ass and make three baskets in a row.
It doesn't mean I have the hot hand.
Only you know when you have the hot hand,
like you feel it,
it feels sensibly different.
Same like in pool.
If you are going to measure people who are on a,
on the role and pool and measuring it by,
okay.
The person who after they run five,
four or five balls,
well it could have been an easy run that you just hit five balls.
Yeah.
When you're in the zone and you're really feeling it,
it's a different thing.
You're absolutely right.
So they have to,
you'd have to basically go to basketball players and say are,
you know,
they'd have to hold up a little,
push a little button,
you know,
and he know.
The problem with that is that it would fuck up.
There's all,
there's moments that you have in food,
right?
Yeah,
there was a moment I was playing in pool.
Uh,
it was me and my friend Eric [inaudible].
Eric,
Chris is the guy who,
uh,
he's a Q maker,
make sugar tree cues.
We were playing and I was fucking running out like every time I got to the
table,
if you left me a shot,
I was running out like a pro and we're playing on a tight diamond.
But it was craziness.
I just,
I couldn't miss,
I just had have this feel of where the ball,
we had been playing for like seven hours and I was just completely lubed up high
as all hell.
And I just had this zone.
I had this feel for where the ball was going.
I knew exactly where it was going at all times.
I can't do it forever.
And then the next day I played again and I was terrible for like the first two
hour only had two hours to play that time and I couldn't get it back.
A good was gone,
but I know it was there the night before it was there.
Man.
It was there.
And because even he was going,
Jesus Christ,
like I never seen you play as good before.
I'd be like,
I've never played this good before.
It's never happened.
But I'm in that thing.
I know.
I know how to do it right now.
It's locked in to zone.
What is Daniel only feel it?
What is that?
What?
That zone.
Who knows?
You know,
I made it.
Look just what you're talking about Joe,
you get into that place where the,
the,
the uh,
the mind boy goes away.
That's not loving your tapping.
That's not luck.
No,
I don't think it is luck.
That's,
I don't,
I'm not sure what it is,
but something lines up with something because we've all been there one way or
another.
Stephen King saying that he didn't even remember certain books that he wrote
because he,
that's where he was.
That lockers,
that cocaine,
whatever the zone is,
cocaine is never connected.
The luck.
Yeah,
that's zone.
It's your authentic swing.
It's when you're really in the doing what it is that you do and nothing else is
blocking you.
Well,
sort of.
It's also with pool.
It's,
um,
it's processing information because there is information,
information's coming back from the queue,
there's information that's coming back from your arm,
your hands,
and then when you processed that information over a long period of time,
then you get so much data that you really understand the dynamics of the table.
You'll really understand the mechanics of your,
you really understand how hard exactly.
You have to hit that ball to make it travel.
Exactly as far as you want it to.
This is a weird thing that goes on and then,
but there's this tipping point moment where you're accumulating,
accumulating,
maybe it's gradual,
more data,
and then all of a sudden it hits a tipping point where your deer,
they're gone.
And that's,
that's where the weirdness happens.
That's where I think there is a little bit of magic.
I think about pool much like everything else is that there's this mindset that
must be maintained and if you think you're going to miss,
you'll fucking miss.
There's a weird thing about pool.
You could line it up,
right?
Everything's telling you like,
fuck,
I'm going to mess by blank.
And you miss.
It's weird.
It's,
it seems like it's such a straightforward thing.
The arm moves straight,
it hits into the ball,
the ball goes straight.
Nope.
If you think you're going to miss,
if you decide right before you're doing it,
fuck,
I hope I don't miss.
You're going to miss.
So how do you diffuse that?
When that little nasty devil comes up either in writing or in Pool,
how do you diffuse that little voice that comes up
that seems to be a self prophecy.
How you've done it,
you've done it,
you know,
I mean there must have been voices at times it's say and it is a form of
resistance,
right?
Well the thing about writing,
of course,
this is always rewriting.
It's not like shoot shooting pool and yeah,
one moment,
you know,
you could screw it up in a,
come back tomorrow and do it a little better.
Yeah.
That's the great thing about writing.
So what about when you're taking that shot,
Joe,
and you get that little nasty voice.
How do you
reset yourself?
I stop,
I stop.
I stopped the voice first of all.
And a,
I usually sit up for a second,
stroke my cue again,
put it down.
I go through like the whole reset through.
That's a very important thing.
Professionals will tell you that people actually coach that.
Like Max.
I really coaches that,
that,
uh,
when you're down a shot,
if you don't like it,
stand up and then begin your whole pre shot ritual again,
get back into position.
Make sure your arms in line you accusing in line.
Go back again and approach it the same way.
Don't ever take a shot where you think you're going to miss,
but I've done it.
I'll do it tonight.
You know,
I do it every time I play.
It's like,
it's,
like I said,
it's a swim.
It's not a mountain climb.
You don't get to the time of plants a flag.
You never win.
You never win with anything.
You just gotta keep going.
You'll Gig,
you get way better than you used to be.
But there's still,
if you're,
as long as you're pushing yourself,
as long as you just still trying to create,
as long as you still trying to get movement going,
you're gonna,
it's not gonna work all the time.
This is going to be flubs.
But those flubs I love him because those,
those signal growth moments for me that the,
the,
at least that's how I have a managed to,
to,
to navigate them.
Every time I fucked something up,
like I can look back in my career as a comedian and my biggest growth periods
came after I fucking ate a plate of shit on stage.
And then I'm like,
Ooh,
I don't want to do that ever again.
And then I figured it out and even like weird sets today like that or it was
like mediocre or I don't like see things didn't come together right.
Or I was tired or I wasn't in comedy shape.
Who does things fucking fire me up,
man.
Nothing makes me want to write more or not.
That makes me want to perform more.
Yeah,
no,
I hear Ya.
I hear you're 100%
well listen man,
I think this is a long enough podcast.
It was an awesome one.
It's been an honor.
How'd you find out about us?
Who told you that?
We were talking about,
yeah.
Uh,
well I related to people all the time who are big fans of your podcast,
you know,
and they say,
Oh,
a a gel rogue.
He's fantastic,
you know?
But also I think we've been in touch via Kelly out ensure a right moms,
my publicity gal.
And uh,
you know,
I think,
uh,
you know,
people have said to me,
hey,
Joe was always talking about your books.
You've got to get on the show,
you know?
And then I think there've been a few times when we've sort of tried to,
or I've tried to really go reach out and something got in the way or something.
So finally,
finally we did
beat it.
Thank you very much.
It's a real honor happened with Joe.
It's a real pleasure to be here with the Werewolf's Aubrey.
It's great.
If you ever have a book that's coming out that you want to promote,
we would be happy to have you on again.
I would love it and we'll promote the shit out of it and I guarantee you a lot
of people going to buy them.
Just from listening to this.
The war of art is the one that I recommend.
If you're looking for a book that's a great book on motivation,
Great Book on overcoming resistance in the creative process.
I haven't read the authentic swing,
but I certainly will.
And I'm going to get into games of gates of fire tonight.
I'm going to get into that tonight.
And,
uh,
anything else people need to find you on Twitter?
It's s Pressfield on Twitter.
Do you do that?
I don't have something else to do.
I don't know about that.
But you don't fuck around with
a website,
a blog.
Your blog is very good by the way.
Just been getting into it.
Steven Pressfield Dotcom.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so that's as s t v Eve with a fee,
not like King Stephen Pressfield with two SS.
Uh,
F I.
E.
L.
D.
Uh,
thank you very much,
man.
That was awesome.
I really,
really,
really enjoyed that.
Thank you.
I forgot.
It's a real pleasure.
And,
uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to a legal zoom,
go to legal zoom.com.
Use the code name Rogan and save yourself some money.
Thanks also to stamps.com go to stamps.com use the code word j r e and get
yourself a $110 bonus offer special offer whenever the hell you want to call it.
And um,
go to meeting a Goto meeting.com.
Use The code word J R E and try it free for 30 days.
All right,
we will see you guys tomorrow.
And,
uh,
we will see you also tomorrow night where the ice house,
it's a Brian red band,
Ian Edwards,
Mat fold trauma,
Tommy Segora,
me and Tony Hinchcliffe too.
It's a hell of a show,
a hell of a show.
$15 10:00 PM come on down freaks.
And um,
this weekend,
Houston Friday night,
I'm at the Bayou you music center with a the great Tom Segura and a then of
course,
Saturday's the UFC.
Uh,
lots of good shit coming up,
including a,
lots of a really cool podcast guests that we got on the horizon.
Uh,
and a cast Berrien from,
uh,
from the young Turks is getting to be here next week and a coming up soon.
We have Sam Harris at the end of the month,
and a lot of other good guests as well.
All right.
We'll see you guys soon.
Much love to everybody.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.